Welcome to another episode of Programming Throwdown. I have a great guest here today. We have Bill Manning. Take it away, Patrick. Welcome to another episode of Programming Throwdown. I have a great guest here today. We have Bill Manning. Bill Manning is a senior solutions engineer for JFrog. Any title he wants. And that's the one we did. Welcome to the show, Bill. Hey, guys. Thank you so much. Yeah, I mean, it's weird. It depends on the day. You know, there's the solution engineering manager one day solution engineering solution architect that guy you see who does youtube and videos on and does talks on that's that's the title that's the one to go with right there you know what it fits really well on a business card oh you know i am all about the business card not quite patrick bateman material like american psycho but you know what i mean you know if we're looking for a little
欢迎收听另一期的 Programming Throwdown。今天我请到了一位很棒的嘉宾，我们请到了 Bill Manning。你来主持，帕特里克。欢迎收听另一期的 Programming Throwdown。我今天请到了一位很棒的嘉宾，我们请到了 Bill Manning。Bill Manning 是 JFrog 的高级解决方案工程师。任何他想要的头衔。这就是我们用的那个。欢迎来到节目，Bill。大家好。非常感谢。是的，我的意思是，这很奇怪。这取决于当天的安排。你知道的，有一天是解决方案工程经理，有一天是解决方案工程解决方案架构师，那个你看到在 YouTube 上做视频、讲座的人——那就是那个头衔，选这个就对了，你知道吗，它印在名片上真的很合适。哦，你知道的，我对名片可是相当热衷的。虽说不像《美国精神病》里帕特里克·贝特曼那种程度，但你知道我的意思，你知道的，如果我们追求一点点那种……
bit of the you know make sure that raised lettering, we're all good. I one time did get business cards and then they promptly sat on my desk and I think I handed out five of them ever. They make great paperweights. Those boxes have a nice heft to them. If you still have paper on your desk, you do that.
那种凸版印刷的效果，那就完美了。我曾经做过一次名片，结果它们很快就堆在我的桌子上，我想我总共大概只发出去过五张。它们倒是不错的镇纸。那些盒子还挺有分量的。如果你的桌子上还有纸质名片的话，你就会这么做。
You just put them there and then you stare at them and you pull them out as nostalgia value and you're like, I should really throw this out. And then you're like, I'll take at least a card and you put that there and then you stare at them and you pull them out as nostalgia value and you're like i should really throw this out and then you're like i'll take at least a card and you put that away and then you shuck the rest right just to prove you had a title at some point that's right that's right i think i still have a stack of them in my garage from my previous company or whatever just like i don't want to throw these out they were cool i think i have them all messed up somewhere in like some like random location i'll pull them out something i go wow that was weird you know it's like yeah it's like the basketball cards i have that my mom brought you know when i became an
你只是把它们放在那里，然后盯着它们看，把它们拿出来纯粹是为了怀旧，然后你会想：“我真该把这玩意儿扔了。”接着你又会想：“我至少留一张吧”，然后你把它放回原处，接着你盯着它们看，把它们拿出来当成情怀，心想“我真该把这玩意儿扔了”，然后你又想“我至少留一张吧”，接着你把它收起来，然后把剩下的全扔了，对吧？就为了证明你曾经某个时候也是个有头衔的人。没错，没错。我想我的车库里现在还存着前公司的一大叠名片什么的，心里就想：我可不想扔掉这些，它们挺酷的。我想我把它们乱七八糟地塞在某个随机的角落里了，有天我把它们翻出来，心想：哇，那可真奇妙。你知道的，就像我妈妈给我留下的那些棒球卡一样。
adult my kids found them and they're like who are all these random basketball players and i'm like i also don't know because like there's some b-string players from like you know when i was a kid that never amounted to anything but it's who's you know you just get randomly distributed cards in the card pack like these are the people you got these are the comments or you can be like me though i used to have at one point when i was a kid i collected the entire star wars top series like for both star wars return of the jedi empire strikes back i had them all together and and they were doing a house cleaning and my brother threw out the entire thing and oh yeah all of it my millennium falcon i still let them i won't let them let them down to this day by the way man it's just it's it's still right here right yeah i
等我成了成年人，我的孩子们发现了它们，然后他们问：“这些乱七八糟的棒球球员都是谁呀？”我说：“我也不知道啊。”因为里面有些乙级球员，比如……你知道的，当我还是个孩子的时候，他们根本没混出什么名堂。但这有什么呢，你就是在卡包里随机抽到了这些卡，这就是你得到的那些人，这就是那些普通球员。或者你也可以像我一样，我以前曾经——当我还是个孩子的时候，我收集了整套的《星球大战》集换式卡牌，包括《星球大战：绝地归来》和《帝国反击战》的。我都收集齐了。结果有一次家里大扫除，我兄弟把整套全给扔了。哦，是的，全部都扔了。我的千年隼号……我至今都还没放过他，我一直没原谅他，真的，伙计。这事儿……它就一直在这儿，没错，真的。
was like do you go on ebay and cry or are you okay i avoid that man because that would just be like me sobbing a lot all right well we normally start off here but before we jump into the the sort of topic of the day, we normally kind of start out just talking to our guests and finding out how you got in tech. And sometimes that's like the first program you wrote. If you have like a memory of like the first computer you got, like whatever, you know, is there like an experience that was just sort of like, yeah, yeah, that was something I sort of remember as early in my journey. Oh, well, yeah. Let's start off with just talking about, you know, I am definitely significantly older, right?
我当时就想：你会去 eBay 上哭着买回来，还是觉得无所谓？我可不敢去看，伙计，因为那样我大概会哭得稀里哗啦的。好吧，我们通常在这里开始节目，但在我们切入今天的主题之前，我们通常会先跟嘉宾聊聊，了解一下你是怎么进入科技行业的。有时候这就像是你写的第一个程序。如果你对得到的台式电脑有什么记忆，不管是什么，你知道的，有没有哪段经历就像是……是的，是的，那是我在自己的旅程中早期还能依稀记得的事情。哦，好吧，是的。让我们先从……你知道的，我绝对算是个老头子了，对吧？
So, I mean, just give an idea, you know, my first computer that I had access to when I was six years old was an Apple II. And that would have been in 1978, early 1979. My mother was a math teacher in New York. And when they, Apple was giving computers because they wanted to show what it can do to schools, even then. And my mother being a math teacher, they were like compute computers, they must go hand in hand with mathematics. And so I came home with a bot with boxes and, you know, all the manuals and stuff. And it kind of sat in our living room. And I was like, what's this and i had always been a sci-fi nerd i mean you know this is like just the way things were and even back then you know space 1999 was like a big thing for me star wars of course
所以，我的意思是，给个概念吧，我6岁时接触的第一台电脑是 Apple II。那大概是在 1978 年或 1979 年初。我母亲在纽约是一名数学老师。当时苹果公司在向学校赠送电脑，因为他们想向学校展示电脑能做什么，哪怕在那个时候也是如此。由于我母亲是数学老师，他们觉得计算机这东西肯定和数学密不可分。于是我妈带回家一箱箱的东西，还有各种说明书之类的一大堆。它们就那样摆在我们的起居室里。当时我就想：这是什么东西？我一直都是个科幻迷，我的意思是，你知道的，事情就是这样。甚至在那个时候，你知道的，《太空1999》对我来说是一部非常重要的作品，还有《星球大战》，当然了……
battlestar galactica you know all these things and i was like computer you know and uh so i took it so i took it out read the manuals put it together busted out the the book that said basic and then just started getting into it then i I went to the Commodore 64. It's funny, actually, is I'm not traditionally trained in terms of computer science or anything like that. Actually, I went to school for philosophy and theology, business, you know, those kind of things. I'd always done it for fun.
《太空堡垒卡拉狄加》，你知道的，所有这些东西。然后我就想：电脑，你知道的……于是我把它拿出来，读了读说明书，把它组装好，翻出了那本写着 BASIC 的书，然后就一头扎了进去。接着我换了 Commodore 64。说实话，挺有意思的是，我在计算机科学或其他方面其实并没有受过传统的科盘训练。实际上，我上学时学的是哲学、神学、商业，你知道的，诸如此类的东西。我一直都是出于好玩才接触这些的。
And then I moved to California from the East Coast. I grew up in New York. I was born in Long Island and I moved to New Hampshire and New England and then moved to California when I was 24, 25 years ago. Well, over 25 years ago now. And yeah, I just I got into it. You know, I didn't know anybody, moved to Silicon Valley, got caught up in the dot com boom, you know, done various tasks over time. But I've always just I've always loved it. To me, it just seemed there was something inherently that my brain just got. You know, I mean, like I can pick up languages very easily.
后来我从东海岸搬到了加州。我在纽约长大的，出生在长岛，后来搬到了新罕布什尔州和新英格兰，接着在 24、25 年前——也就是现在二十五年前——搬到了加州。嗯，现在已经远不止二十五年了。对啊，我就是这样入行的。当时我谁也不认识，搬到硅谷，赶上了网络泡沫的浪潮，随着时间推移做过各种各样的事情。但我一直都……我一直都很热爱它。对我来说，似乎有一种内在的东西，我的大脑一下子就能理解。你知道的，也就是说，我可以非常轻松地掌握各种语言。
I can, I've actually started companies based on my approach. So like what I wanted to learn MPM, I wanted to learn node, right? I started playing with it and started the company called XTV, you know, got investment and all that, but it all started because I wanted, I was curious. I liked the idea of server side and client side JavaScript, right? To me, I was fascinated, but just by the concepts, you know, this would have been, you know, and I was just like, okay, great. So I dove into it, learned it and then decided I was like, hey, you know what, I think I found a good application to
我甚至根据自己的方法创立过公司。比如我想学 NPM，我想学 Node，对吧？我开始摆弄它，然后创办了一家名为 XTV 的公司，你知道的，拿到了投资什么的。但这一切的开始都只是因为我好奇。我喜欢服务器端和客户端 JavaScript 的概念，对吧？对我来说，我深深地被这些概念迷住了。这大概是……我当时就想：太好了！于是我一头扎进去，学会了它，然后决定说：“嘿，你知道吗，我觉得我找到了一个很棒的应用场景……”
use this for. And it was fun. You know what I mean? So like my entire career has been a journey of also to making sure that every company I've either started or every company that I've worked in with friends, usually, I've always done startups, is something completely different every time. I never picked the same technology twice. That's always been my rule. I got into this industry for a reason. So my first company was Web-based CRM. We were the first Web-based CRM. A lot of the people went on to found Marketo, Sugar CRM, helped build Salesforce and all that.
可以用它。而且这很有趣！你知道我的意思吗？所以我的整个职业生涯也是一段旅程，确保我创办的每一家公司，或者我和朋友们（通常都是朋友）一起工作的每一家公司，每次都做完全不同的事情。我从来没有重复使用过相同的技术。这一直是我的铁律。我进入这个行业是有原因的。所以我的第一家公司是基于网页的 CRM。我们是第一家基于网页的 CRM 公司。后来很多人去创办了 Marketo、Sugar CRM，帮忙打造了 Salesforce 等等。
I went from there, did email encryption and security in my next company. And we sold that one. And that was great. Next one was IoT before IoT. It was actually called the Connected Home. I actually have a bunch of awards behind me over here. We actually created a platform for IoT back in 2006 and 2007. Once the ES awards for, you know, basically we wrote a protocol layer that allowed us to like bridge
我从那里离开后，在下一家公司做电子邮件加密和安全。我们把那家公司卖了，感觉挺棒的。再下一家是物联网爆发前的物联网。它其实被称为“互联家庭”。其实我身后的这里挂着一堆奖项。我们在 2006 年和 2007 年其实就已经为物联网打造了一个平台。赢得了 ES 奖，你知道的，基本上我们编写了一个协议层，让我们能够将……
all the various IoT technologies like Z-Wave, Zigbee and all those into a common language called FCML. Actually, it's funny as FCML is called a few, we call it the fluid communication meta language. Really overly complicated name for what it did, but it was a translation layer. Yeah, you know, I mean, like I said,
所有各种物联网技术，比如 Z-Wave、Zigbee 以及所有这些技术，桥接到一个名为 FCML 的通用语言中。其实挺搞笑的，FCML 有好几个名字，我们叫它“流体通信元语言”（Fluid Communication Meta Language）。这名字对它的功能来说实在是过于复杂了，但它本质上就是一个翻译层。是的，你知道的，就像我说的……
and then did media for a while. I did some work as a VC with Lord of Adventures. That was fun. Mentorships. And I've done a lot of things over time. And my latest one, of course, is I joined over six years ago, I joined JFrog. And now I'm helping build tools and work with companies for better, more efficient software development and also safer software development. And to me, that's really important. And actually, I really fell in love with the concepts of being able to do this, right? Because I get to work with people, I get to help make things safer, more efficient. And to me, that's really awesome.
后来还做了一段时间的媒体。我在 Lord of Adventures 做过一段时间的 VC。那段经历挺好玩的。还有导师项目。随着时间的推移，我做过很多事情。而我最近的项目，当然就是六年前我加入了 JFrog。现在我正在帮助构建工具，并与企业合作，以实现更好、更高效的软件开发，以及更安全的软件开发。对我来说，这非常重要。实际上，我真的爱上了能够做到这一点的概念，对吧？因为我可以与人们合作，我可以帮助使事情变得更安全、更高效。对我来说，这真的是太棒了。
Like, you know, take my wealth, you know, all my years and decades of experience and be able to shape it into something. It feels weird saying that, man. Yeah. Yeah. I'm, I'm, uh, I'm not there, but I'm almost there as far as, uh, saying those same things and being like, get off my lawn. Okay. Go back just a little bit. Uh, okay. A lot. Uh, you sort of started out there. I wanted to kind of, so you said you went to school for, well, first of all, that's kind of interesting, philosophy and theology. And then you ended up moving to Silicon Valley. Okay, I think I missed something there. What, how did you decide to have, you know, go to school for that and take the move out to Silicon Valley?
就像，你知道的，把我所有的财富——我是说，我所有多年和几十年的经验——塑造成某种东西。说出这话感觉怪怪的，伙计。是的。是的。我……我……我还没到那一步，但差不多也快到那个境界了，可以开始说出同样的话，然后变成那种冲着别人喊“从我的草坪上滚开”的人。好的，稍微倒回一点……好吧，倒回很多。你刚才差不多是从那里开始的。我想……所以你说你上学学的是……首先，这挺有意思的，哲学和神学。然后你最后搬到了硅谷。好吧，我觉得我中间漏掉了一点。什么……你是怎么决定去学那个专业，然后又搬到硅谷的？
Was there, was there something there? Well, it's funny, is it because I've always, you know, even when I was doing that, I always still was still doing it right behind the scenes to me it wasn't like i never you know it's funny i don't think i ever really looked at it as a career is more of just a thing i did right you know i mean like since i was a kid and stuff you know like whether it was you know playing games writing my own games you know back on my commoner 64, when I had that, right. And then that worked up into my first PC, my first, you know, i386. And, you know, like, oh, my God, you know, this is this whole new world out there for me. And, you know, teaching myself way back, you know, when long ago, you know, like, all right, well, you know, I first Linux, you know, sets of Linux, I started working,
中间有什么特别的原因吗？嗯，挺逗的，因为我一直……你知道的，甚至在我做那些事情的时候，我其实一直在幕后折腾着这些技术。对我来说，它不像……我从来没有（你知道这很搞笑）真正把它当成一种职业来看待，它更多只是我做的一件事情，对吧？你知道我的意思吗？就像我从小到大做的那样，不管是……你知道的，玩游戏、在我的 Commodore 64 上编写自己的游戏（当我拥有它的时候，对吧）。然后这些经验积攒起来，变成了我的第一台 PC、我的第一台 i386，然后，你知道的，天哪，你会觉得这个全新的世界向你敞开了大门。而且，你知道的，很久很久以前我就开始自学了，你知道的，比如……好吧，我最早接触的一套 Linux、几套 Linux 开始上手的时间大概是 1994、1995 年，编译我自己的内核。你知道的，对我来说，这就像是……所有这些书呆子做的事情都是为了我个人，我从来没把它当成是一份职业，它就是我所做的事。与此同时，就像我说的，我在做这些的同时……甚至在我上大学的时候，我读大学学的就是那个专业，但我当时还在一个硬核金属乐队里弹琴。然后呢，你知道的……（硬核金属乐队，你知道的，去即兴合奏，做这些事情），然后还玩 DND（龙与地下城）、电脑游戏和编程。你知道的，感觉我当时什么都干。
looking at 1994, 95, compiling my own kernel, you know, I mean, to me, it was just like, all this nerd stuff i did for me personally and i never looked at it that way it was just what i did you know at the same time it's like while i was doing that like i said i was going like even like when i was in college that's what i was going to college for but like i was playing in like a hardcore metal band also and then you know like you know hardcore metal band you know jamming doing that and then playing dnd and and computer games and programming. You know, it was kind of like I was all over the place.
然后我的好朋友搬到了硅谷，我以前也来过这里（北加州），并且我爱上了这个地方。所以我说：你知道什么？我有什么好失去的呢？我要去那里闯一闯，靠着自己的头脑在这个行业里谋生。然后，我就这样开始了，我开始越来越多地自学，当我意识到我是多么、多么由内而外地……甚至都不是为了找工作才去做的。我当时就想：哇。我心想，我真的意识到这就是我。这就是……这就是我最快乐的地方。就像我待在一个 shell（命令行界面）里就无比快乐。所以说，挺有意思的是，我一直都需要和人们打交道，我还得管理团队以及处理各种各样的事情，
And my best friend moved to Silicon Valley, and I'd been here before, you know, Northern California, and I fell in love with it. So I said, you know what? What do I got to lose? I'll go out and thought my way into the industry. And like, just, I just started, I started teaching myself more and more when I realized how much I really, really inherently, it wasn't even like I was doing it to get a job. I was like, wow. I'm like, I really realized that this is me. This is, this, this, this is where I'm happiest. Like I'm like, I'm really happy in a shell and happy. You know, so it's funny as I work with people all the time and I have to manage people and all these things,
但有时候我最快乐的时光依然是：戴上耳机，敲着键盘，开着 shell，打开 IDE（集成开发环境），对吧？然后亲手创造出点什么。当我学习一种新语言时，我依然会感到兴奋。几个月前我开始自学 Rust，因为我想学它，对吧？它是成长最快的语言。它具备了我大脑喜欢的那种特质，会让我觉得“这太棒了”，对吧？我的意思是，它拥有像 Java 那样的堆内存管理和内存清理机制，但又兼具 C 和 C++ 的速度与效率。它具备极高的可移植性，对吧？你甚至不需要运行时环境。对我来说，我当时就想：天哪，你这些年都跑哪儿去了？你知道我的意思吗？就是那种感觉。所以，当我第一次让自己的第一组代码跑通的时候，我当时就想：这太酷了。你知道的……就像我第一次让自己的第一组代码跑通的时候，我心想：这太酷了。你知道的，我就像是在想：噢，我在生成 HTML！但与此同时，我又能够去操纵我的树莓派上的芯片，你知道的，用同一种语言在同一时刻开始闪烁 LED 灯。我当时就想：这太疯狂了。我心想，它居然能与微处理器建立这种桥梁，但同时它又能在同一种对象类型中创造出视觉元素。我心想：这怎么可能做得到？你知道我的意思吗？
but there's still some times where I'm happiest, where I've got my headphones on, I've got my keyboard, I've got my shell, and I've got my ID, right? And I'm creating something. I still get excited when I'm learning a new language. I started teaching myself Rust a couple months ago, because I wanted to learn it, right? It's the fastest growing language. It has all the things in my brain that go, this is awesome, right? I mean, it's got the heaps kind of stuff and memory, you know, cleanup that you would get with Java, but it's got the speed and efficiency of C and C++. It's highly portable, right? You don't need a runtime. Like to me, I was like, oh my, where have you been
所以你刚才提到了那件事，然后我顺着往下说。但你提到曾去北加州游玩，然后，你知道的，就爱上了那里。其实我觉得这是一件大家平时不太会去多谈的事情。每个人都把硅谷当作科技公司和在那里工作的人的一个代名词、一个标签。但我觉得人们在某种程度上低估了这片区域究竟有多美。
all my life? You know what I mean? Those kinds of things. And so like, I still like, when I first got my first set of things working, I was like, this is cool. You know, like, I still like when I first got my first set of things working, I was like, this is cool. You know, like, I'm like, Ooh, I'm generating HTML. But at the same time, I'm able to go ahead and manipulate the chip on my Raspberry Pi, you know, to start flicking LEDs at the same time with the same language. I'm like, this is insane. I'm like, it's got this bridge to the mic, you know, to the microprocessor. But at the same time, it can create a visual element all within the same object type. I'm like, how is that even possible? You know what I mean?
即使有这么多人在那里生活，如果你在那里呆过、生活过，你就会发现它真的拥有非常惊人的自然美景，能够轻松前往公园和进行徒步旅行，有太多好玩的事情了。这太疯狂了。你想想看，还有什么其他地方，从技术层面上讲，你能做到这一点？
So you mentioned something there and then I'll sort of take it forward. But you mentioned going and visiting Northern California and, you know, kind of falling in love with it. I actually think this is something that people don't talk very much. Everyone sort of knows Silicon Valley as the sort of like semantic label for the group of tech companies and people that work there. But I think it's somewhat underrepresented just how beautiful the area is.
而且我真的认识一些人，他们就这么干过。我知道你要讲什么故事了。好吧。出发。在太浩湖过夜。早上醒来。去太浩湖痛快地滑几次雪。钻进你的车里。
Even with so many people living there, having spent time and living there, it really is a very beautiful, like natural beauty, access to parks and hiking, just like the amount of things to do. It's crazy. Think of any other place where you could technically, technically you could do this.
开车南下。沿途停下来。打九个洞的高尔夫球。再钻回车里。然后前往海边。去冰冷的加州、北加州的海水里泡一泡。谢谢你指出这一点。没错。去游个泳，然后在海滩上聚一聚、办个篝火晚会，对吧？就在一天之内。一天之内。是的，这真是一个美丽的地方。
And I actually know some people who have done this. I know what story you're going to say. Okay. Go up. Spend overnight in Lake Tahoe. Wake up in the morning. Go for a quick couple of skis in Lake Tahoe. Get in your car.
哦，是的。我的意思是，我是一名骑行爱好者。那是我的精神发泄方式。我热爱骑行。老实说，这里绝对是数一数二的骑行胜地。我的意思是，我们有数千英里的步道、无数的山丘。而且当我提到山丘时，跟东海岸相比，它们基本上就是大山了，对吧？因为它们海拔有 3500 英尺甚至更高，你知道的，诸如此类。而且是的，正如你所说，我的意思是，我距离圣克鲁斯的的海滩只有 25 分钟的车程，你知道的，这真的很棒。我的意思是，这就是我喜欢这里的原因，这里的气候温和。是的，别误会我。房价确实高得离谱。每个人都会问：“那地震怎么办呢？”然后我就会说：“好吧。”尤其是对我的好朋友们，我会说：“我们这里可没有什么‘地震季’，就像你们那里有‘龙卷风季’一样，你知道我的意思吗？”或者像飓风季。对不起，伙计。我的意思是，你在佛罗里达。我父母也在那儿。这就好像，你们那边有龙卷风季……你知道我的意思吗？或者飓风季。对不起，伙计。我的意思是，你在佛罗里达。我父母也在那儿。这就好像，你们那边有个季节，而我们这儿纯粹是靠随机的好运。我们在那儿掷骰子，地震可能会发生，也可能不会发生，你知道的。你知道的，人们会大惊小怪地说：“噢，你们刚刚经历了 4.1 级或者 3.6 级地震。”然后我说：“我们确实经历了，对吧？”你住在这里，你就会觉得……人们会问：“你被晃到了吗？”然后我说，我当时只是以为有人在卸货。有一辆半挂大卡车从旁边开过。是的。
Drive down. Stop along the way. Play nine holes of golf. Get back in the car. And then go out to the ocean. Take a dip in the freezing cold California, Northern California ocean. Thank you for calling that out. Yes. But go for a swim and then hang out and have a bonfire on the beach, right? In one day. One day. Yeah. It is a beautiful area.
然后你提到坐在那里敲键盘时感到很快乐。所以我想知道，你的键盘敲击声有多大？你是个键盘发烧友吗？哦，是的，我是。这是我的 Keychron K1。
Oh yeah. I mean, I'm a cyclist. That's my outlet. Like, I love cycling. And to be honest, this is one of the greatest places, bar none, to cycle. I mean, we have thousands of miles of trails, tons of hills. And when I say hills, they're basically, compared to East Coast, they're mountains, right? Because they're like 3,500 feet and higher, you know, and all these. And yeah, like you said, I mean, I'm 25 minutes from the beach in Santa Cruz or, you know, and it's great. I mean, that's the reason why I loved it here is the weather is temperate. Yes, don't get me wrong. Housing prices are insane. Everybody's like, what about the earthquakes? And I'm like, okay. And especially my best friends, I'm like, we don't have earthquake season where you have tornado season, you know what I mean? Like, or hurricane season. I'm sorry, dude. I mean, you're in Florida. My parents are there too. It's like, you guys have tornado season you know i mean like or hurricane season i'm sorry dude i mean you're in florida my parents are there too it's like you guys have a season ours is just random luck in there we're gonna roll the dice and you know it might happen might not you know you know people are like oh you guys got a 4.1 or 3.6 and i'm like we did yeah you believe it
我觉得它棒极了。它是一款超薄键盘。他正在向我们展示，对于那些看不见的人来说……哦，他们看不见。他键盘底部发光的炫酷美感。那可能是我这辈子见过最亮的键盘了。极其亮。我其实是为了你才把它打开的，就是为了向你展示一下。我通常是把它关掉的，但事实是，而且是的，它使用的是……在这个例子中，这款是青轴。青轴。我通常……我通常把它关掉，但事实是，而且是的，它使用的是……在这个例子中，这款是青轴。青轴，好吧。
you lived here you're like people like did you get rattled? And we're like, I'm like, I just thought somebody was dropping something off. A semi-truck was driving by. Yeah. And then you mentioned being happy sitting there typing on your keyboard. So I got to know how clicky is your keyboard. Are you a keyboard enthusiast? Oh, yes, I am. And this is my Keychron K1.
青轴。我通常会选茶轴，尤其是在我的办公室里，因为……是的，青轴在办公室里可不招人喜欢，对吧？不，不。我的意思是，当它听起来就像你手里抓了一大袋冰块，而且还一直在你身边不停地摇晃时，周围的人……所以如果我们听到你的屋顶上有冰雹落下的声音，那其实只是你在播客录制期间随手打字的声音而已。就是那个声音！不过说真的，我超喜欢这款键盘，因为它是超薄设计的，而且它的反馈感太棒了。是的，我的意思是，我还以为发生地震了，结果其实只是 Bill 在修复 NPM 里的 Bug。哦，原来如此。完全正确！人们会问：那是什么声音？听起来像下冰雹一样。那是什么噪音？不过说真的，挺有意思的，其中一个最棒、最让人满足的键盘其实是……我几乎应该把它拿起来贴到麦克风旁边让你听听，因为那台电脑已经有 40 多岁了。它其实是一台 Apple IIc。哦，好吧。我拥有的一台。那台机器的键盘声音简直绝了。我绝不撒谎。它是我用过声音最清脆、最有段落感、敲起来手感最爽的键盘，而且……
I think it's fantastic. It's a super low profile. He's showing us, for those of you who can't see. Oh, they can't see. The underlit beauty of his keyboard. That might be the brightest keyboard I've ever seen in my entire life. Extremely bright. I actually turned it on just for you, just to kind of show you. I usually keep it off, but the fact is, and yes, it is using, actually in this case, this one is the blue. The blue switches. I usually go it off, but the fact is, and yes, it is using, actually in this case, this one is the blue. Blue, okay.
就像我说的，我有一台……他们看不见，但我有一台……我有一堆这种电脑摆在我身后。我有 Mac SE、Apple II、Apple IIc，各种型号。嗯，我很喜欢这些东西。对，我以为你要说的是 IBM Model M 呢。也就是那种……人们会花离谱的高价去买，或者在旧货店里淘到它，然后拍下自己修复它的视频发到网上，配文说“看我找到了什么”。是的，其实我车库里就有一台。它真的就在我车库里，我有很多那种老键盘。不过对的，我以前确实有一台，而且我还专门买了一个转接头，把 PS/2 接口转成 USB 接口，因为在那个年代，就像我刚才说的，那种手感实在是太惊人了。那种弹簧屈曲机构（buckling spring mechanism）。
The blue switches. I usually go with the brown, especially in my office because- Yeah, blue is not nice for your office, you patriots, yes? No, no. I mean, when it sounds like you're just grabbing a bag full of ice and constantly shaking it next to you and the people. So if we hear the sound of hail on your roof, that's just you typing momentarily during the podcast. That's it right there. But no, I love this because it's super low profile. And the feedback on it is fantastic. Yeah, I mean, I thought that there was an earthquake, but it was actually just Bill fixing bugs in NPM. Oh, there you go. Exactly. People like what's
人们总是会满怀诗意地赞美他们键盘的机械结构。不过话说回来，我得说我这款打起来手感也相当不错。我必须承认，在所有我用过的键盘里，我是 Keychron 的超级粉丝。我觉得它们真的非常扎实，特别是它有金属底盘和金属边框。所以，我的意思是，它本身是有分量的。因此当它放在那儿时，你可以尽情地在上面疯狂输出。
that? It sounds like hail. Like, what's that noise? You know, it's funny, though, one of the best most satisfying keyboards is actually I should almost grab it and hold it up to the mic just so you can hear it because the computer is over 40 years old. It's actually an Apple IIc. Oh, okay. That I have. And the keyboard to sound on that thing is spectacular. I am not going to lie. It is the clickiest, clackackiest most positive feeling keyboard ever and
手感太棒了。我打字完全不会觉得累。等着吧，等你发现有那么多人把磁性细导线焊接在柔性 PCB（印制电路板）上，然后用 3D 打印出根据每根手指长度雕刻的参数化键帽时……那种量身定制的？等着瞧吧。这就跟定制西装一样。就像是定制键盘。但这款不一样，因为它……
i like i said i have a they can't see it but like i have a i have a couple i have a bunch of those computers behind me i've got like my mac se my apple 2 apple 2c everything um yeah i like that stuff yeah i thought you were gonna talk about the yeah model m which is the like i mean where people pay obscene like they find it in the thrift store and they like video themselves and put it on the internet look what i found and they restore it yeah i actually have one of those in my garage it's actually in my garage i've got a lot of those but yes i used to have one of those and i had the adapter for the ps for the uh the interface ps2 to usb adapter because in those days i like I said, that feel was amazing. The buckling spring mechanism.
好吧，你知道你一天花多少时间在打字上吗？这完全对得起它的价格。这就跟你买的床一样。你知道你在床上花多少时间吗？基于这个理由，我可以向你证明任何花费都是合理的。顺便说一句，在 JFrog，我们其实有一个专门讨论键盘的 Slack 频道。哦！
People will wax poetic about the mechanism by which their keyboard types. This one feels pretty good too, though, I will say. I will say the Keychron, out of all the ones I've used, I'm a huge fan of Keychron. I think that they're really solid, especially it's got a metal chassis and it's got a metal frame. So, I mean, it just has weight to it. So when it's there, you're just jamming away on it.
真的。我们有一个专门聊宠物的频道，一个专门聊键盘的频道，还有一个专门聊乐高的频道。当然，少不了乐高。好吧，没毛病。好了，你带我们回顾了你的经历。我还有一个评论，因为这是经常有人写信来问我们的一个问题，而且我觉得很有趣：近年来，由于我们姑且称之为宏观经济趋势的影响，这种情况似乎有点起伏不定。但你提到了那种只想努力奋斗、不断展现自我的精神，那并不是你的背景，
It feels great. Like I don't get tired on it at all. Just wait until you find out about all the people like soldering magnet wire to like flexible PCBs and 3D printing sculpted per parametric per finger length. Bespoke? Just wait. It's like a bespoke soup. It's like bespoke keyboard. But this one's different because it's...
但那是你的热情所在。而且你确实就是这么干出来的。我没听到你说过——如果我错了请纠正我——噢，你重新回学校去读了个别的学位，然后拿到了什么学历证书，从而完成了镀金。这是一个人们经常写信来向我们征求建议的辩论：用你的话说，是最好一头扎进去，努力奋斗去争取编程工作并一步步往上爬，还是停下手头的事情去获取一纸文凭再杀入这个行业？你对这有什么看法吗？我只是好奇，因为你展现了一个非常独特的背景。这是一个非常……你知道的，这其实是一个非常有趣的问题，对吧？因为这两种方式都有其价值，而且很搞笑的是，
Well, do you know how many hours a day you spend typing? Like it justifies that. It's the same thing like your bed. Do you know how many hours you spend in your bed? I can justify any amount to you based on this. By the way, at JFrog, we actually have a Slack channel dedicated to keyboards. Oh.
因为我的意思是，在我的某一份工作里，我记得和我共事的几乎所有人——可能是我共事过的最优秀的工程师中的一部分——都出自我的第一家初创公司。关键在于，其中有一大批人都是从斯坦福、加州大学以及所有那些学校毕业的，绝对都是才华横溢。我记得当时对我来说有一个特别搞笑的时刻，那就是作为自学成才的我，买来各种书一头扎进去、苦苦奋斗，我发现把这两种途径结合起来其实相当棒，尤其是在软件开发方面。你拥有更传统的学院派方法，对吧？也就是他们擅长的领域，我从他们身上学到了大量的东西。但与此同时，我也认为我不那么正统的方法同样收到了不错的效果，
Seriously. We have one dedicated to pets, one dedicated to keyboards, and one dedicated to Legos. Of course, Legos. Okay, yes. Fair enough. All right, so you took us on the journey. One other comment I had, just because it's something that people write into us about and I think has been interesting is it feels like it's ebbed versus flowed a little, I guess, in recent years, just to do to let's call it macroeconomic trends. But you mentioned sort of just wanting to grind it out, showing up that that wasn't your background,
因为我解决问题的方式略有不同。我认为两者的结合是相当关键的。是的，如果我回过头来看，我是否希望自己当时就能意识到这就是我的菜呢？或者，你知道的，我其实一直隐约知道，但我从没想过真的会把它当作一份职业，特别是——你得记住我都 50 多岁了，对吧？——而且，你知道的，我看到……我开始上学的时候已经是 80 年代末、90 年代初了。在那段时期，这种专业能力本身其实并不是很普及。它确实存在，但……而这才是更搞笑的部分，
but it was what you were passionate about. And you sort of like worked it. I didn't hear you say, and please correct me if I'm wrong. Oh, you went back to school, you got a different degree, and you sort of got the pedigree, you sort of round up. And this is a debate that, you know, people write in and ask for our advice, is it better to go out, let's just use your term, sort of grind it out and sort of try to get programming jobs and build your way up or to stop what you're doing and go get the credentialing to make it in? Do you have any thoughts there? Just curious, because that's a sort of unique background that you presented. That's a very, you know, it's funny is that's a very interesting question, right? Because there is value in both, right? And it's hilarious,
那就是现在，你知道的，我认为网络泡沫确实把编程在某些情况下推到了类似摇滚巨星般的地位，从某种程度上讲，对吧？突然之间，那些搞这行的人竟然开始变得……出名了。他们开始频繁地出现在公众视野里。这完全是另一种不同的状况。
because I mean, in one of my jobs, I remember I worked with almost everybody I worked with, probably some of the best engineers I've ever worked with, and was one of my first startups. The thing is, is that, and there was a bunch of them that graduated from like Stanford and Cal and all, you know, from like Berkeley and all those absolutely brilliant. And I remember a moment for me that was hilarious was, you know, being self-taught and, and like getting the books and just diving in and grinding it out is that having both is actually pretty awesome, especially in terms of developing software. You have the more traditional collegiate approach, right? Which is like, you know, where they excelled and I learned tremendous amount from them. But at the same time, I think my unorthodox approach also voted well,
别误会我。就像我正在读的书——我手头正在读的这本书，我其实想读很久了，最近终于开始读了——就是托尼·法戴尔（Tony Fadell）写的《Build》（中文版《打造》），对吧？如果你还没机会读这本书，这绝对是一本神书，对吧？里面讲述了他在苹果公司的历史，以及在此之前的通用魔术（General Magic）时代的经历。因为在 90 年代初那个时期，他们开发了人类历史上第一款真正融合了 PDA、手机、也就是基本上把通信设备握在手里的产品。我的意思是，那款设备里的所有东西，其实就是后来所有人创造出 iPad、iPhone 的先驱。
like, because I attacked the issues slightly different. And I think the combination of both is pretty essential. Yes. Did I take, if I'm looking back, do I wish I realized that this was my thing? Or, you know, and I always kind of knew it, but I just never thought I would actually consider that as a career, especially, you know, you gotta remember I'm over 50, right? And, you know, I saw, you know, this was like back, you know, when I started going to school was the late 80s, early 90s. And during that time period, that professional ability wasn't really out there per se. It was, but, and this is the funnier part,
你知道的，赫茨菲尔德（Hertzfeld）和所有那些人都出身于那个团队，并创造了 iPad、iPhone、iPod 等等，那个群体真的引领了潮流。但问题是，甚至连他们直到 2000 年代初都还没真正获得广泛认可。所以就像我说的，回过头来看，如果当时能更早理解我的天赋，理解我在那个方面的个人优势，我希望自己或许能用那种方式来切入。但与此同时，我的大脑能让我顺理成章地走到今天，其实我也感到非常庆幸，对吧？而且在某些情况下，正因为我是一步一个脚印苦干出来的……顺便问一句，你想知道我当初进入这个行业的最主要原因是什么吗？
is that now it's, you know, I think the dot-com boom really pushed it into, in some cases, programming as like a rockstar persona in some respects, right? Suddenly, you know, the guys who were doing this stuff suddenly were actually becoming, you know, famous. They were becoming visually out there. Like it was a very different thing.
对我的影响最大的那个原因？我简单插一句。我们在第 153 期节目中确实讨论过托尼·法戴尔的书《Build》。所以各位听众，如果你正在听节目，并且想买这本书，请务必、务必、务必访问我们第 153 期的节目shownotes（节目文稿），点击那个链接，那能帮到我们的节目。太棒了！所以我要去听听第 153 期节目。录完这个之后，真的，因为就像我说的，我对它超级着迷。但是……
And don't get me wrong. It's like I'm reading right now, like the book I'm reading right now, I was being meaning to read for a while. And I finally started reading was like Bill by Tony Fadell, right? If you haven't had a chance to read it, it's a phenomenal book, right? It's his history at Apple and before that, you know, during the general magic era, because back in that time period in the early 90s, they developed the real first like mixture of PDA, cell phone, you know, basically a communication device in your hand. I mean, everything in that device actually was the precursor of all the people from there. You know, Hertzgag and all those guys came from, you know, from that and created, you know, the iPad, the iPhone and, you you know, the iPod and all that, like that group really set the trend. But like, the thing was, is that even they weren't recognized until the early 2000s. So like I said, going back, I wish understanding my aptitude,
你知道的，关键在于……而且这是给每一个学生、每一个考虑从事这一行的人，或者那些已经在职场中、正寻求转行的人的建议。我当初进入这个领域的最大原因并不是因为……因为我的确具备这方面的天赋，但事实是，我在不断学习，对吧？我没有停滞不前。而且顺便说一句，这并不是每个人都会一直发生的事情。我认识行业里一些同龄人，他们有点江郎才尽了，对吧？他们死守着一样东西不放，然后在行业经历经济衰退的时候——就像现在这样以及之前的衰退——过得很艰难。不论他们是不是科班出身，或者是不是自己苦学出来的，关键在于：要适应，对吧？要不断学习。你踏入这个行业是有原因的。这很让人兴奋，对吧？你身处于一个不断演进的生命体之中，对吧？你知道的，它总是在进化，总是在改变，它不是一成不变的，你知道我的意思吗？对我来说，如果让我过那种朝九晚五、枯燥乏味的生活，整天盯着 TPS 报告、盖着无聊的戳子，我真的会死的，我真的会发疯的。事实是，当新技术出现时，我的第一反应总是：噢，好闪亮啊！我想去研究一下。就像我刚才说的，比如 Rust，你知道我的意思吗？我就想：如果我要跟我的客户进行恰当的合作，我就必须理解其中的细微差别，对吧？
understanding my own personal strengths in that respect, that I wish I had maybe approached it that way. But at the same time, I'm actually very fortunate in my brain that I didn't, right? And in some cases, because I did kind of grind it out. And by the way, you want to know the main reason why I got into the industry?
我必须去理解。对我来说，其实这才是最令人兴奋的部分，对吧？当你正在经历这一切、刚刚开始入门时，你写出了第一个“Hello World”，你知道的！哪怕只是那头一个，你也会想：好吧，行吧，我搞定了一个 Hello World。这挺棒的。但这并不是那个总能让我兴奋的点，因为那只意味着“我的开发环境已经准备就绪，现在我终于可以开始学习了”，对吧？然后当我深入进去，开始做一些事情，比如：噢，我要弄一个多类数组，我可以在里面进行这样那样的操作。然后我开始写代码，并输出了一个结果，结果我一看：这跟我预期的完全不一样！我大概是写错了，我可能得回去好好检查一下，对吧？因为代码从来不可能一次性就写对。但当你意识到“哇，我居然搞砸了”的时候，那种感觉反而更加令人兴奋。说实话，这其实是我最喜欢的环节，因为如果我一次就写对了，我会觉得我根本没有足够深刻地理解那些技术细节。而如果我真的把它搞砸了，那就意味着我必须去弄懂怎么修复它。对我来说，而且事情就是这样，我和其他工程师聊过，计算机科学（CS）非常适合学习理论、抽象思维，以及通过算法构建公式化模型等等。但有一点……我哥们的儿子现在正在伯克利读计算机项目，所以他在上大学。我对他说：你知道的，调试（Debugging）。其中有一点，我在职业生涯早期的时候——等等，甚至在我的职业生涯开始之前，还记得我说过我小时候在 Commodore 64 上玩电子游戏吗？现在，各位，这听起来可能会显得很老土、很过时、很疯狂。
The biggest one for me? Real quick, if I just interject. So we did talk about Tony Fadell's book, Build, on episode 153. So folks out there, if you're listening, and you want to buy the book, please, please, please go to our show notes for episode 153. And click the link that helps out the show. There you go. Fantastic. So I'm gonna go check out episode 153. After this, actually, because like I said, I'm really fascinated by it. But
但在 80 年代初，当我拥有我的 Commodore 64 时，你知道的，我有一个小小的 CRT 显示器，对吧？其实那是一台电视机，你必须把它调到 3 通道，然后调整它才能玩游戏。人们根本不知道你在说什么！对，完全正确！你必须把它调到 3 通道，因为它还会发出那种声音。然后你还得插上……我有一个重达 40 磅的硬盘……你知道的，我其实有一个软盘驱动器，那个软盘驱动器在你真正去使用它的时候，会发出那种非常悦耳的声音。但如果我想玩某些游戏，我就必须去……
you know, the thing was, is that and this is for every student or every person that's ever, you know, looking to do this, or if they've already have, you know, looking to change careers or whatever. The main reason why I got into this was not for like, because I mean, yes, I like I have the aptitude for but the fact is, I'm always learning. Right? I'm not stagnant. And by the way, this is not a thing perpetually that happens for everyone. I know people my age in the industry that kind of fizzled out, right? They stayed with one thing and then they've had tough times in their career where things have had recessions, like what's going on now and starting in this, even if they're going to school or they're grinding it out, whatever, you know, is the fact is adapt, right? Constantly learn. You're in this for a reason. It's exciting, right? You're in an ever-changing organism that's in it, right? You know, it's always evolving. It's always changing. It's not stagnant. It's, you know what I mean? And to me, I would die, seriously, if I was like in a nine to five grind job where I'm, you know, looking for TPS reports and stamping crap, right? I would lose my mind. You know, the fact is, is that when a new technology comes out, my first reaction is, ooh, shiny. You know, I want to go check it out. Like I said, like Rust, you know what I mean? I was like, if I'm going to work with my customers properly, I need to understand the nuances, right?
把零花钱省下来……说实话，当我对那些不了解这段历史的人说起这件事时，这听起来真的很荒谬……省下零花钱去买一盒软盘，把它们带回家，然后用打孔器在软盘上打个洞，把它变成双面的，这样我就可以两面都用了。因为它们其实本来就是双面的，只是通常人们只用单面。但如果你在另一侧打个孔，你就可以把它反过来插进去使用另一侧。与此同时，如果你想玩其中某些游戏，你还得买一本杂志。你带着杂志回到家，里面会有大概 15 页的代码，你必须把它们手动敲进去才能玩这个游戏。这会花很长时间。但我必须说，我觉得正因为我不得不把所有那些代码——大概 15 到 20 页、采用 10 号字的小字代码——全部亲手敲进去。
I need to understand. And to me, actually, that's the exciting part, right, is when you are going through it and you are starting in, you get that first light, the hello world. You know what I mean? Even that first one, you're like, okay, fine. I got a hello world. That's great. That's not the one that always excites me because that's just like, okay, that means my environment's prepped and now I'm ready to learn, right? And then when I go in and I start doing things like, ooh, I'm going to make a multi-class
就像是微型字体一样。然后再让它运行起来，接着还要回去调试它。真的，你知道的，我因此获得了一种能力：我能看懂任何系统中所生成的日志。当我们构建系统之类的东西时，假设我正在开发一个功能，我必须盯着日志。我觉得正是因为当年的经历，我培养出了一种模式识别能力，我可以看着日志从眼前滚动过去，然后说：“停！”别人就会问：“你看到了什么？”我说：“停！”然后他们就会说：“好吧，往回看。”
array where I can go in and blah, blah, blah. And I start doing something and I produce an output and I go, that was not what I expected. And I probably did it wrong. I probably should go in and check it out, right? Because it's never going to be right the first time. But that's even more exciting when you realize that, wow, I screwed up. Actually, to be honest, that's my favorite part is because if I did do it right the first time, I feel like I don't understand the nuances enough. And if I do screw
这是一个我可以随意操作的数组，诸如此类。然后我开始做一些事情，产生了一个输出，心想，这和我预期的不一样。我可能做错了。我可能应该去检查一下，对吧？因为事情绝不可能第一次就做对。但当你意识到“哇，我搞砸了”时，这就更令人兴奋了。说实话，这其实是我最喜欢的部分，因为如果我第一次就做对了，我会觉得我对细微差别的理解还不够。如果我真的搞砸
it up, that means now I got to learn how to fix it. And to me, and here's the thing is, and I've talked to other, you know, engineers and stuff, and CS is great for learning theories and abstract thoughts and being able to go ahead and build up formulated models with algorithms, blah, blah, blah. One thing that, and my buddy's son right now is at one of the programs at Berkeley, right, so he's going for college. And I said, I go, well, you know what, debugging. Like, one of the things is, is that early in my career, and here we go, and actually not even before my career, remember I said I played video games, like, when I was a kid on my Commodore 64. Now, here we go. And actually, not even before my career. Remember I said I played video games like when I was a kid on my Commodore 64. Now, here we go, guys. Now, this is going to sound old, antiquated, and crazy.
了，这就意味着现在我得学会怎么修复它。对我来说，情况是这样的，我和其他一些工程师聊过，计算机科学（CS）非常适合学习理论、抽象思维，以及构建带有算法的公式化模型等等。有一点，我朋友的儿子现在正在伯克利的一个项目里读大学，对吧？我对他说，你知道吗，调试（debugging）。比方说，在我职业生涯的早期，甚至在我的职业生涯开始之前，还记得我说过我小时候在Commodore 64上玩电子游戏吗？现在，我们要说到这个了。实际上，甚至在我的职业生涯之前。还记得我说过我小时候在Commodore 64上玩电子游戏吗？现在，伙计们，我们要说到这个了。这听起来可能很古老、过时而且疯狂。
But back in the early 80s when I had my Commodore 64, you know, I had my little CRT monitor, right? It was a TV. They had to put it on Channel 3 and, you know, adjust it so that you could play. People have no idea what you're talking about right exactly right you had to put it on channel 3 because it had like it actually had that sound and then you plug i had i had a hard disk that weighed like 40 pounds uh you know i actually had the floppy drive and the floppy drive would give this really satisfying when you actually would go in and actually use it but if i wanted to play some of the games i would go
但在80年代初期，当我拥有我的Commodore 64时，你知道的，我有一个小CRT显示器，对吧？那是一台电视。你必须把它调到3频道，然后调整它以便你能玩。人们根本不知道你在说什么，完全正确，你必须把它调到3频道，因为它有那种声音，然后你插上——我有一个重达40磅的硬盘，你知道的，我其实有个软盘驱动器，那个软盘驱动器会发出一种非常悦耳的声音，当你真正去操作和使用它的时候。但如果我想玩某些游戏，我会去
and i would save my money by the way this sounds really ridiculous when i say this to people who don't understand save my money to go buy a box of floppy disks bring them home by the way and use a hole puncher to make them double-sided so that i can make them actually so i can use both sides because they were actually were double-sided it's just you only people use one but if you hole punch the other side you could put it in and use the other side. But at the same time, if you want to play some of these games, you would actually get a magazine. And you'd come home with the magazine, and there would be like 15 pages of code that you had to manually type in to play this game. And it would take a long time. But I will say, I think because I had to go in and type it every, all that code in, 15 to 20 pages, we'll say, of little, you know, we're talking like 10 font, right?
存钱——顺便说一句，当我把这番话讲给那些不懂的人听时，听起来真的很荒谬——存钱去买一盒软盘，把它们带回家，顺便说一句，用打孔器把它们改成双面的，这样我就可以把它们——实际上我就可以两面都用，因为它们本来就是双面的，只是大家只用一面。但如果你给另一边打个孔，你就可以把它塞进去使用另一边。但与此同时，如果你想玩其中一些游戏，你其实得买一本杂志。你带着杂志回家，里面大概有15页的代码，你必须手动输入才能玩这个游戏。这需要很长的时间。不过我要说的是，我想正因为我必须进去把所有的代码都输入进去，大概15到20页的小字，你知道的，我们说的是那种10号字体，对吧？
Like micro font. And then having it run and then having to go back and debug it. Really, you know, I have like this thing where I can look at a log in any system that's been built. When we build systems and stuff, and say I'm working on a feature and I've got to watch the log. I think because of that, I've got pattern recognition that I can look and watch logs go by and be like, stop. And people are like, what did you see? I'm like, stop. And they're like, well, go back.
就像微型字体一样。然后让它运行，接着还得回去调试它。真的，你知道的，我有这样一种能力：我能看懂任何已构建系统中的日志。当我们构建系统之类的时候，假设我正在做一个功能，我必须盯着日志。我想正是因为这个，我才有了模式识别能力，我看着日志滚动，然后就会说：停。人们会问：你看到了什么？我说：停。他们会说：好吧，倒回去。
And I'm like, there it is. I can visually, for some reason, but I think a lot of that has to do with me back then coding by hand like hundreds of lines and being like 10 or 11 years old and doing this and being like and then having to figure out what went wrong now picture having to go through all that without even a real debugger or a compiler you know the ability to set a breakpoint didn't exist so you know like you couldn't set a breakpoint to see oh maybe it's, you know, the ability to set a breakpoint didn't exist. So, you know, like, you couldn't set a breakpoint to see, oh, maybe it's here, you know, oh, maybe on that path, you know, maybe the value is wrong. So I think there's a combination of things that people need to know. And I think people should, you know, definitely, you know, you're in an industry
然后我就觉得，就是它了。不知为什么，我可以直观地感受到，但我认为这很大程度上与我当年十一二岁时，自己手写几百行代码，写完后还要去找出哪里出错了有关。现在想象一下，在甚至没有真正的调试器或编译器的情况下经历这一切，你知道的，当时根本没有设置断点的功能，所以，你知道的，你无法设置断点去查看“哦，也许是……”，你知道的，当时根本没有设置断点去查看的功能。所以，你知道的，你无法设置断点去查看，哦，也许在这里，你知道的，哦，也许在那条路径上，你知道的，也许数值不对。所以我认为这是人们需要了解的各种因素的结合。而且我认为人们应该，你知道的，绝对地，你知道的，你身处一个
that's ever evolving, number one. Number two, you should always go in and do the hard stuff because that'll help you learn, right? You know, debugging the hard things, like go online, look at Stack Overflow, look at some of the discussions there, find some sample code from some person's GitHub, take it down, look at it, and then try to figure out
不断发展的行业中，这是第一点。第二点，你总是应该去攻克困难的部分，因为那会帮助你学习，对吧？你知道的，调试那些困难的事情，比如上网看看Stack Overflow，看看那里的某些讨论，从某个人的GitHub上找一些示例代码，把它下载下来，看一看，然后试着弄清楚
why this discussion was happening by looking at all the commits, right? You know, find some of these and be like, oh, look, you know, I wasn't getting a return value because of this or I wasn't implementing a function correctly because of this. And somebody gives a good explanation to Stack Overflow. I learned a lot of that, you know, like in the early 2000s when Stack Overflow was like starting up and all this kind of stuff in those discussion forums. And I learned a lot by screwing up. Yeah, I think there's like you bring up some great points. I mean, a lot by by screwing up yeah i think there's like you you bring up some great point i mean a lot to dig in there we will just ignore all of it and move to
为什么会发生这个讨论，通过查看所有的提交记录，对吧？你知道的，找到其中的一些，然后想，哦，看，你知道的，我因为这个而没有得到返回值，或者我因为这个而没有正确实现一个函数。有人在Stack Overflow上给出了很好的解释。我学到了很多这方面的知识，你知道的，比如在2000年代初期，Stack Overflow刚刚兴起的时候，还有那些讨论论坛。我通过不断犯错学到了很多东西。是的，我觉得——你提出了一些很好的观点。我的意思是，有很多——通过不断犯错学到了很多东西。是的，我觉得——你提出了一些很好的观点。我的意思是，有很多内容可以深入探讨，我们先不管这些，直接进入
our next topic but i mean i'm gonna say i'm like sorry i know that was a lot to throw at you but you know what i mean it's great i think what what i'll counterbalance there and i think you did it you you kind of mentioned it like do the hard parts where i think sometimes early in a career people say i try this technology i don't want to just move the next one, move the next one, move the next one. And it's not what you're saying. You're not telling people. I don't hear you telling people,
我们的下一个话题。但我的意思是，我只想说，抱歉，我知道刚才塞给你太多信息了，但你知道我的意思吗？这很棒。我想我可以从中调剂一下，我觉得你也做到了——你稍微提到了这一点，比如去做那些困难的部分。我觉得有时候在职业生涯的早期，人们会说：“我尝试了这个技术，我不想只是转向下一个，转向下一个，转向下一个。”这并不是你想表达的。你并没有告诉大家。我没听到你告诉人们，
like try something if you don't like it, just move to the next flavor of the day, framework of the month, whatever it is. And just keep, you're never getting work done in your code base. You're just rolling your code base around through some weird search of the space. You're not saying that you're
比如尝试某种东西，如果你不喜欢，就直接换成当下的新潮流、每月的框架，无论是什么。然后一直……你根本无法在代码库中完成任何工作。你只是在漫无目的地通过某种对空间的怪异搜索来回折腾你的代码库。你不是在说那个，你是在说
saying get good at something do the hard parts but at the same time don't say i've found something that works nothing better could ever be invented exactly and that's actually one of the problems with don't get me wrong like i said i work with all different types of technologies i do a lot of our public speaking right i'm fortunate enough now, like I said, it's funny is that like I found the place where I feel like I can take all the garbage that I have in my brain and have an outlet for it that's constructive.
精通某项技术，攻克难关，但同时也不要说“我找到了一个行之有效的方法，绝不可能发明出更好的东西了”。没错，这其实就是——别误会我，就像我说的，我和各种不同类型的技术打交道，我做了很多公开演讲，对吧？我现在很幸运，就像我说的，有趣的是，我找到了一个地方，我觉得我可以把我脑子里所有的垃圾拿出来，并为它们找到一个具有建设性的出口。
You know, like, you know, be able to, you know, talk about things like I love talking. It sounds ridiculous when I say it out loud now. You know, like one of the things I think we're having this discussion about was like software supply chain, right? You know, what is software supply chain? People ask this all the time. Meanwhile, it's the most systemic problem in the industry right now, right? So, you know, software supply chain is all the things that you use to build the stuff that
你知道的，比如，能够，你知道的，谈论一些事情，比如我喜欢说话。现在大声说出来听起来挺荒谬的。你知道的，比如我们正在讨论的事情之一，就像软件供应链，对吧？你知道的，什么是软件供应链？人们总是问这个问题。与此同时，这是目前这个行业中最具系统性的问题，对吧？所以，你知道的，软件供应链就是你用来构建你作为开发者所构建的东西的所有东西，
you build as a developer, right? You know, 85 to 90% of all code is someone else's code that you don't know. I always say this when I give my talks and I mean it wholeheartedly coming from my life, which is I always say, look, developers are artisans. They're, you know, they're artists. They really are, you know, right? You know what their medium is, whatever, you know, is programming, right?
对吧？你知道的，所有代码中85%到90%都是别人的代码，而你并不认识。我在做演讲时总是这么说，而且我是发自内心地这么认为的，结合我的人生经历，我总是说，听着，开发者是工匠。他们是，你知道的，他们是艺术家。他们真的是，你知道的，对吧？你知道他们的媒介是什么，无论什么，你知道的，就是编程，对吧？
And whatever language they use, you know, instead of it being, you know, instead of being titanium white, you know, it would is whatever you know is programming right and whatever language they use you know instead of it being you know instead of being titanium white you know would be some titanium white oh wow that was very that was very specific yes but right but you know what you know what i mean like you look at a situation you you you assess the situation and if you're fortunate enough to have a you know start something you can choose the technology you feel best way or either way you feel comfortable with or feel is best for the appropriate thing you're trying to solve or you go into a situation where the product's already built and you work with the technology stack or whatever but the thing is software supply chain is all the stuff you utilize right so that that medium and the thing, is that one of my favorite quotes,
无论他们使用什么语言，你知道的，与其说是，你知道的，与其说是钛白，你知道的，会是——无论你知道的，就是编程，对吧？不管他们用什么语言，你知道的，与其说是，你知道的，与其说是钛白，你知道的，那会是某种钛白——哦，哇，那个非常、非常具体。是的，但是——对吧，但你知道的，你知道我的意思吗？就像你审视一种情况，你评估这种情况，如果你足够幸运能够开始做某件事，你可以选择你觉得最好的技术，或者你觉得舒服的技术，或者你认为最适合你试图解决的问题的技术；或者你进入一个产品已经构建好的环境中，你与技术栈或其他东西合作。但关键是，软件供应链就是你利用的所有东西，所以这种媒介和——而且有一件事，我最喜欢的一句名言，
and I use it in all my talks, is that like, why are you so passionate about protecting software supply chain? I'm like, number one, a lot of the customers I deal with are, I'm a customer of theirs. So yeah, I want to make sure that my experience is good and make sure my data is secure. My banking materials are good. You know what I mean? And I'm not alone. I want to make sure that my experience is good and make sure my data is secure. My banking materials are good. You know what I mean? Like I'm doing it and I'm not alone. I want to help in that respect. Because basically the thing was it came from Dan Lornick.
我在所有的演讲中都会用到它，那就是：为什么你对保护软件供应链如此充满激情？我说，第一，我打交道的很多客户，我也是他们的客户。所以是的，我要确保我的体验是好的，并确保我的数据是安全的。我的银行资料是安全的。你知道我的意思吗？而且我不孤单。我要确保我的体验是好的，并确保我的数据是安全的。我的银行资料是安全的。你知道我的意思吗？就像我在这样做，而且我并不孤单。我想在这方面提供帮助。因为基本上这件事是来自Dan Lornick。
And what he said was, is that every time you pip install, go get Maven Fetch, it's something you do with is the equivalent of plugging a thumb drive you found in the gutter into your production server. Right. It's true. Because the thing is, let's see, you know, the thing is, is that how do you not squash the ability for developers to really develop, be artists? You know, I mean, their code is crap. I mean, think about it. I mean, building an algorithm is no different than building, you know, something structurally or creating a sculpture, right? You're molding, you're malleating, you know, things. But at the same time, how do you ensure that you're not using lead paint, that you're not using tainted clay, you know, that might have some sort of latent E. coli because you're like, oh, I got some Mayan mud that I'm going to go build something with. And they're like, yeah, sure. I found it here. Use it.
他说的是，每次你执行pip install、go get、Maven Fetch，这做的事情就相当于把你从臭水沟里捡到的U盘插到你的生产服务器上。没错。这是真的。因为事情是这样的，让我们看看，你知道的，事情是这样的，那就是：如何既不扼杀开发者真正进行开发、成为艺术家的能力？你知道的，我是说，他们的代码就是垃圾。我是说，想想看。构建一个算法与在结构上建造某物或创作一个雕塑没有什么不同，对吧？你在塑造，你在锤打，你知道的，各种东西。但与此同时，你如何确保你没有使用含铅油漆，你没有使用受污染的粘土，你知道的，里面可能含有某种潜在的大肠杆菌，因为你想：“哦，我弄到了一些玛雅泥，我要用它来造点东西。”然后他们会说：“行啊，没问题。我在这找到的，用吧。”
And it's containing something. Right. And so my thing is, is that like what we're doing at my, you know, the company I work with, Janefrog, is that we're trying to protect that. But at the same time, stop the hindrance of, you know, doing it behind the scenes, ensuring that those third-party transitive dependencies, because that's what they are, right? I need to parcel.
而且它包含了一些东西。对吧？所以我的意思是，我们在我工作的公司Janefrog所做的事情，就是试图保护这一点。但与此同时，不要阻碍在幕后进行的工作，确保那些第三方的传递性依赖项——因为它们就是这样的，对吧？我需要解析。
I mean, you guys are programmers, right? I want to parse a string, and I want to find a particular value in that string. I'm using the most basic example, right? I could go in there and write a regular expression thing that goes in and says, hey, tear this apart, look for it. Or maybe I have to do something special with it. Maybe I have to encode it.
我的意思是，你们是程序员，对吧？我想解析一个字符串，我想在那个字符串中找到一个特定的值。我用的是最基础的例子，对吧？我可以进去写一个正则表达式，进去说：“嘿，把这个拆开，寻找它。”或者我可能需要对它做一些特殊处理。我可能需要对它进行编码。
I have to encode it a specific way for some reason. Yeah. And I'm using Python. I'm going to go out and look for a Python library that maybe says input is a string, output is a blah. And I go, hey, that's great. It saves you time. And I go, hey, that's great. You just, you know, right? It saves you time. And I'm going to use it. Now, the thing is, is that in this world today, the problem is, is that that software supply chain, and the reason why you hear about it so much is the fact that
出于某种原因，我必须以特定的方式对它进行编码。是的。而我正在使用Python。我要去寻找一个Python库，它可能会说输入是一个字符串，输出是某某。然后我说：“嘿，这太棒了。它为你节省了时间。”然后我说：“嘿，这太棒了。你只需要，你知道的，对吧？它为你节省了时间。”然后我就要使用它。现在问题是，在当今这个世界，问题在于，这个软件供应链——以及你为什么经常听到它的原因——在于
those transitive dependencies, you don't know where they're coming from. But at the same time, you still want to have that naive approach to solving a problem. And you don't want to think that the world is a terrible place, right? You know, you try to keep optimistic. But just give you an idea. In 2021, there was a 650% increase in supply chain tax alone. And it went up 40% last year. Think about that. 85% to 90% of the things that you rely on as a developer can be potentially nefarious or malicious. And we're not just talking nice, you know, like, ha, ha, ha, funny hack thing. You know, we're talking detrimental. I mean, the one that everybody always talks about and the example I always about, because it was $100 billion remediation globally, it was 18,000 customers, including the DOD, DHS, Federal Reserve, you name it, right, was, of course, SolarWinds. Now with SolarWinds, that was, I'm sure you guys did a podcast on that at some point, or maybe or not, I don't know. But that was actually a fourth level transit dependency, right? It was a fourth level, I don't know. But that was actually a fourth level transitive dependency,
那些传递性依赖项，你根本不知道它们来自哪里。但与此同时，你仍然想对解决问题保持那种天真的态度。你不想认为这个世界是个糟糕的地方，对吧？你知道的，你尽量保持乐观。但给你们一个概念。在2021年，仅供应链攻击就增加了650%。去年又增长了40%。想想看。作为一名开发者，你所依赖的东西中有85%到90%可能具有潜在的危害性或恶意。我们谈论的不仅仅是那种美好的，你知道的，比如“哈哈，好笑的黑客小把戏”。你知道的，我们谈论的是具有破坏性的。我是说，每个人都在谈论的那个例子，也是我经常举的例子，因为在全球范围内造成了1000亿美元的修复成本，有18000家客户受到影响，包括国防部、国土安全部、联邦储备委员会等等，你知道的，当然就是SolarWinds。现在说到SolarWinds，那是一个——我确信你们在某个时候也做过关于这个的播客，或者也许没有，我不知道。但那其实是一个第四层的传递性依赖项，对吧？那是一个第四层的——我不知道。但那其实是一个第四层的传递性依赖项，
right? It was a fourth level, actually indirect transitive dependency. Okay. So I'll double click. Can you maybe, so transitive dependency, you dropped it a couple of times. Maybe just take one step and just let folks know so they can follow along with, what do you mean by a transitive dependency? Oh, sorry. Sorry. Yeah, sure. No, you're good. You're good. So anytime you're programming and you choose? Whether it's C, right? And you're using a header file and you're pointing to a library, right? That library you might use or Python or NPM, right? You get a node module. Those are libraries. Libraries are dependencies, things that you depend on to do your code, right? Like I said, 85 to 90% of code you write have dependencies. That's what they are.
对吧？那是一个第四层，实际上是间接的传递性依赖项。好的。那我深入探讨一下。你能稍微——所以传递性依赖项，你刚才提了好几次。也许能退后一步，让大家跟上节奏，让他们明白你所说的“传递性依赖项”是什么意思？哦，抱歉。抱歉。是的，当然。不，你讲得很好。你讲得很好。所以任何时候你在编程并做出选择时？无论是C语言，对吧？你正在使用头文件并指向一个库，对吧？那个库你可能会使用，或者Python，或者NPM，对吧？你获取一个节点模块。这些都是库。库就是依赖项，是你编写代码所依赖的东西，对吧？就像我说的，你编写的代码中85%到90%都有依赖项。它们就是这样的。
And then a transitive dependency is you have implicit or direct, which you state that you want to use this library. But those libraries that you're utilizing, right, those dependencies you're using have dependencies. And those dependencies have dependencies, thus it's transitive, right? It goes down the stack. And the thing is, you have implicit, like I said, or direct, which is the ones you usually put in your code. Like if you're doing NPM, it's package.json, right? You put your dependencies in,
然后传递性依赖项就是，你有隐式依赖或直接依赖，也就是你声明你想要使用的库。但是你正在利用的那些库，对吧？你正在使用的那些依赖项也有依赖项。而那些依赖项又有依赖项，因此它是传递性的，对吧？它会沿着依赖树向下延伸。事情是这样的，你有隐式依赖，就像我说的，或者直接依赖，也就是你通常放在代码中的那些。如果你在使用NPM，那就是package.json，对吧？你把依赖项放进去，
you put in your specific versions or wildcard versions or whatever. You should never use wildcard versions. Please stop using wildcard versions. Just saying. It's like, you should also be using Docker. Please erase the word latest from your head. Stop it now. Anyway, that's a whole other digression right there. But the thing is, is those dependencies are the threat, right? They're the threat. You know, I always equate it to is the
你放入特定的版本、通配符版本或其他什么。你永远不应该使用通配符版本。请停止使用通配符版本。我只是顺便提一句。这就好比，你也应该使用Docker。请从你的脑海中擦除“latest”这个词。立刻停下来。不管怎样，那是另一个题外话了。但关键是，这些依赖项就是威胁，对吧？它们就是威胁。你知道的，我总是把它比作
idea of like a, you know, I wouldn't say like a Trojan horse per se, but picture you're in a castle. You're protecting your castle and your citizens and you're having a good time, right? Suddenly a horde of angry invaders comes from the east and from the west. Oh, I'm starting to sound like the Lord of the Rings here, right? They're coming in, you know, they're coming over the hills and all this stuff, right? And suddenly somebody goes, hey, you know what? It might be easier if we just open the door, right? Let them in. What's the worst that could happen, right? Because basically what you're doing is, is that, you know, some of them are friends, some of them are foes, some of them you don't know, right? These dependencies, and you're basically, you're letting them in to your company, right?
一种——我不会说像是特洛伊木马本身，但想象一下你在一座城堡里。你在保护你的城堡和你的市民，你们过得很开心，对吧？突然，一群愤怒的入侵者从东边和西边涌来。哦，我听起来有点像《指环王》里的角色了，对吧？他们涌进来，你知道的，他们翻山越岭，诸如此类，对吧？突然有人说：“嘿，你知道吗？如果我们直接把门打开，也许会更容易，对吧？让他们进来。能发生的最坏情况是什么，对吧？”因为基本上你所做的就是，你知道的，他们当中有些是朋友，有些是敌人，有些你根本不认识，对吧？这些依赖项，而你基本上把它们放进了你的公司，对吧？
And it's not just a destroyer of potential lost revenue. The biggest threats are actually reputation, right? Are you really gonna go work with a company, again, that just took all your data and shipped it off somewhere and put it on the black market, right? Or are you gonna go with one that's a little more secure, right, that you don't read bad headlines about. And the thing is, is that the threat model is insane. I mean, to give you an idea, in security land, when it comes to transitive dependencies,
这不仅仅是潜在收入损失的破坏者。最大的威胁其实是声誉，对吧？你真的会去和一家公司合作吗？再次强调，这家公司刚刚拿走了你所有的数据并把它们运到某个地方，放到了黑市上，对吧？或者你会选择一家更安全一点的公司，对吧？不会招致负面新闻的公司。问题是，威胁模型太疯狂了。我是说，为了让你有个概念，在安全领域，当涉及到传递性依赖项时，
right? When it comes to threat models, there's a thing called a zero day, right? Everybody hears about the zero day, meaning that is the moment that that issue became an issue. That's the threat, right? Zero day. It's start, you know, you know, I always have to explain to some people. I'm like, when you count in programming, you always start off with zero, one, two, three, right? You always start with zero, right? Like whenever I describe things, I always start with zero.
对吧？当涉及到威胁模型时，有一个东西叫做零日漏洞，对吧？每个人都听说过零日漏洞，意思就是那个问题成为问题的那一刻。那就是威胁，对吧？零日漏洞。它开始，你知道的，你知道的，我总是向某些人解释。我说：在编程中数数时，你总是从零开始，0、1、2、3，对吧？你总是从零开始，对吧？就像我描述事物时，我总是从零开始。
So thus zero day, right? And then it goes up from there. And when zero, you know, the thing is, is that since 2021, 40% of the zero day exploits of all time have happened. Think about that. And it's done by volume, just a sheer number of actual issues in this kind of third party space, right? These transitive dependencies, the things you don't know. And the thing is, is that when this happens, how do you protect your organization? How do you protect yourself? How do you do it in such a way that you're not squashing your developers' ability to create? You know, because you don't want them to be hindered, but you can do it in a way that's actually productive. And like, we try
所以因此有了零日漏洞，对吧？然后从那里往上递增。当零——你知道的，事情是这样的，自2021年以来，历史上40%的零日漏洞攻击都发生了。想想看。而且这是按体量计算的，仅仅是这种第三方空间中实际问题的绝对数量，对吧？这些传递性依赖项，那些你不知道的东西。问题是，当这种情况发生时，你如何保护你的组织？你如何保护你自己？你如何以一种不扼杀你的开发者创造能力的方式来做到这一点？你知道的，因为你不想阻碍他们，但你可以用一种真正富有成效的方式来做到这一点。就像我们努力
to do that as a company. That's one of the things that we do. Like we provide IDE tools to say, hey, you know, that library you're using is potential threat, is a potential threat. And, you know, we're a CNA. We're actually a CVE member authority. We actually have a giant research team that does this stuff. And I'm so happy about that. Like I said, I take this very personally. I think it's, and I love the ability for me to go out there and work with the organizations, to stand on stage, to do webinars, to talk here, and be able to say, you know what? You can still do what you do, but you can do it safely. You can do it securely. You can do it in a way that can also be preventative. And that's one of the
作为一家公司来做这件事一样。这是我们所做的事情之一。比如我们提供IDE工具来告诉你：“嘿，你知道的，你正在使用的那个库是一个潜在威胁，是一个潜在威胁。”而且，你知道的，我们是一个CVE编号颁发机构（CNA）。我们实际上是一个CVE成员权威机构。我们有一个庞大的研究团队专门做这件事。我对此感到非常高兴。就像我说的，我对此非常重视。我认为这是——而且我喜欢能够走出去与各种组织合作、站在舞台上、做网络研讨会、在这里演讲，并能够说：“你知道吗？你仍然可以做你正在做的事，但你可以安全地做。你可以稳妥地做。你可以用一种具有预防性的方式来做。”这就是其中的一个
things, like we just released a new feature to me that is fantastic. One of the biggest things is companies spend millions of dollars on basically trying to remove these threats, right? And the thing is, is that, put it this way, for every threat that you detect in one of these transitive dependencies, you're detracting from the developer's ability to go in and develop, right? You're now doing a threat assessment model instead of an innovative model, right? Like I always joke around. I was like, wouldn't you rather, you know, we're doing a campaign now I'm working on called Innovate More, Remediate Less. The thing is, is that we actually can go in there and tell the developer, the security person or whatever, that this CVE, which is a CVE, just so you know, is actually the assessment of a library in terms of threat, right? So there's
方面，比如我们刚刚发布了一个对我来说非常棒的新功能。其中最重要的一件事情是，公司花费数百万美元基本上试图消除这些威胁，对吧？问题是，换句话说，你在这些传递性依赖项中检测到的每一个威胁，都在削弱开发者进入并进行开发的能力，对吧？你现在是在做一个威胁评估模型，而不是一个创新模型，对吧？就像我经常开玩笑说的那样。我当时想：“难道你不想——我们现在正在开展一个我参与的项目，叫做‘更多创新，更少修复’。”关键是，我们实际上可以进入其中，告诉开发者、安全人员或任何人，这个CVE——顺便让大家知道，CVE就是对库在威胁方面的评估，对吧？所以有
low, medium, high and critical. Critical, of course, means that you should burn it, burn it, burn it. Log4j, right? And we'll talk about that in a minute, if you guys don't mind, because that one's always hilarious because there was things that were leading up to it that everybody ignored, right? The thing is, is that being able to pinpoint them and act on them quickly saves them the ability for time to, okay, address the issue, go back to my KPIs. Like, where do I have to release this sprint, right? Yeah, so let me just dig into a couple of things there. So I think you've mentioned this,
低、中、高和严重。严重程度当然意味着你应该把它烧毁、烧毁、烧毁。比如Log4j，对吧？如果你们不介意的话，我们一会儿会讨论这个，因为那个总是让人觉得很滑稽，因为在它之前发生了一些事情，而所有人都忽略了，对吧？关键是，能够精确定位它们并迅速采取行动，为他们节省了时间来：好的，解决问题，回到我的KPI。比如，我必须在哪个冲刺（sprint）中发布这个，对吧？是的，那我来深入探讨其中的几个问题。所以我想你已经提到了这一点，
and I find this very interesting. And I guess not everybody realizes it. Someone told me long ago, I have no clue who, but this way that you're sort of speaking, I'll use an analogy to talk about lawyers the same way. People will say, hey, we're at a company and we're trying to figure out whether we can do this. So we're going to go talk to the lawyers. Maybe I don't mean to demean other people or say maybe everyone knows this, but I didn't. And it was an educational experience to me the first time I sort of worked with it this way. The lawyer's job is to tell you no. The lawyer is just going to say the safest thing for you to do to not have legal risk is don't do whatever you're asking. It doesn't matter if it's literally the business case. It doesn't matter. They would just say the safest thing is for you to shut your business down and not do it anymore.
我发现这非常有趣。我想并不是每个人都意识到这一点。很久以前有人告诉我，我完全不知道是谁，但你说话的这种方式，我可以用一个类比来谈论律师，也是一样的。人们会说：“嘿，我们在一家公司，我们正试图弄清楚我们是否能这样做。所以我们要去和律师谈谈。”也许我不是故意贬低其他人，或者说也许每个人都知道这一点，但我不知道。当我第一次以这种方式与他们合作时，这是一次很有教育意义的经历。律师的工作就是对你说不。律师只会告诉你，为了不承担法律风险，你能做的最安全的事情就是不要做你正在询问的任何事情。这是否真的是业务案例并不重要。这不重要。他们只会说，最安全的事情就是你把公司关掉，再也不要做这件事了。
Okay. Well, thank you. That's not helpful. Okay. So what is it? And it's your sort of job as a person looking for legal feedback to go to the lawyers and say, well, what are my risks? And then you need to own those risks. Now they may tell you, I guess you were sort of alluding to this. Your risk is that the department of Justice is going to knock down your door with the SWAT team and haul you off to prison because this is a felony. Don't do those things. Other things are going to say, well, there is a chance that someone could get hurt. And you say, well, okay, well, I'm going to counter that by going getting liability insurance or designing a safer product or documenting, right? There's this
好吧。嗯，谢谢。这没有帮助。好吧。那是什么？作为寻求法律反馈的人，你的工作就是去找律师并说：“好吧，我的风险是什么？”然后你需要承担这些风险。现在他们可能会告诉你——我猜你刚才在暗指这一点——你的风险是司法部会带着特警队砸开你的大门，把你抓进监狱，因为这是一项重罪。不要做那些事。其他事情会说：“嗯，确实有人受伤的几率。”然后你说：“好吧，好吧，我要通过购买责任险、设计更安全的产品或做好文档记录来对抗这种风险，对吧？”有这种
balance and counterbalance, but going to a lawyer whose job it is to tell you the risks, they're going to tell you risks. And so I think this is this balance that you're speaking about, which is the safest code is do not write code. Well, maybe not, but it's have no code at all. Okay, but we can't do that, right? Like we want to write some code. And so balancing these things out. And as you point out, there are libraries that are extraordinarily helpful, the open source stuff just can't be ignored anymore. And lots of companies tried to, and I think all of them have given up at this point. And so there are many companies that want to ignore these things. But it is very difficult because you pick it even if you did an audit, even if you reviewed line by
平衡与制衡，但是去找一个职责就是告诉你风险的律师，他们就会告诉你风险。所以我认为这就是你所说的这种平衡，也就是最安全的代码就是不要写代码。好吧，也许不是，但这就是根本没有代码。好吧，但我们做不到这一点，对吧？我们需要写一些代码。所以要把这些事情平衡好。正如你所指出的，有些库是非常有帮助的，开源的东西再也不能被忽视了。很多公司都曾试图忽视，我想他们现在都已经放弃了。所以有许多公司想要忽视这些事情。但这非常困难，因为你选择了它——即使你进行了审计，即使你逐行进行了审查。
line. And even if you were capable of detecting a bug, you use latest. And that doesn't mean that next month, they don't add a new dependency, or they don't change what they're doing, right? This is a very subtle, but difficult, like, environment. Yeah, but let me unpack that, right? So there's a couple of things, right? So let's talk about the legal side first, right? There's there's a couple of different functions here in terms of legal that you have to be cognitively aware of, right? There's, of course, the greater one, which is protection, ethical, and those kind of questions, right? Take it from somebody, you know, I think earlier on, we were kind of before this started, we were talking a little bit like chappy GPT, right? Before I joined JFrog, I actually had a startup where we actually built something very akin.
即使你有能力检测出漏洞，你使用了latest版本。这并不意味着下个月，他们不会添加新的依赖项，或者他们不会改变他们正在做的事情，对吧？这是一个非常微妙但困难的，类似于这样的环境。是的，但让我剖析一下，对吧？所以有几件事情，对吧？所以我们先来谈谈法律方面，对吧？这里有几个不同的法律职能，你必须在认知上有所意识到，对吧？当然，有更高层次的那个，也就是保护、道德以及诸如此类的问题，对吧？听听过来人的话，你知道的，我想在早期，我们在开始之前，我们谈论了一点像ChatGPT这样的东西，对吧？在我加入JFrog之前，我其实有一家初创公司，我们在那里构建了一些非常类似的东西。
I still have all the code in my source code, by the way. And we actually had I had an office in San Francisco, had a bunch of my friends. And I we built an ad based AI engine. Right. And I'll tell you right now, I had a hard time. Five. This is six years ago, almost seven years ago. Hard time getting funding because it was too creepy. Oh, that was that was the exact that was the exact words from what was and i was in the vc space and these are friends of mine who were like love what you're doing this is pretty awesome but god i'm gonna do a hard pass uh this seems a
顺便说一句，我所有的代码仍然保留在我的源代码中。我们实际上有一个——我在旧金山有一个办公室，有一群朋友，我们构建了一个基于广告的AI引擎。对吧。我现在可以告诉你，我当时很难获得融资。五年前。这是六年前，快七年前了。很难获得融资，因为它太让人毛骨悚然了。哦，那就是——那正是当时的准确原话，我当时在VC（风险投资）领域，这些都是我的朋友，他们说：“喜欢你在做的事，这挺棒的，但我天哪，我得坚决拒绝。呃，这看起来
little bit almost borderline unethical and i had to think about interesting okay i was kind of hurt uh basically what it was is it was i won't say what technologies helped us at this but there was a point where i was i was able to take messages 1200 characters you know 1200 words from a customer from a consumer and construct it with my algorithm construct a media campaign around them specifically targeted towards them based on their exact who they are oh okay like their likes their dislikes favorite colors things like that but do it in a way that was very it was yeah and i admit looking back now yeah it might have been like might have been might have been a little much i also might have harnessed the power of watson at one point to kind of help me parse through this data faster. But that's neither here nor there. That's one aspect of it. I had to do a lot of legal talks. I had to do a lot of ethical talks around this. Then there's the next side of this, financial and reputation. They're kind of hand in hand. Your reputation is strong. Your revenue should be strong. Your reputation is strong. Your revenue should be strong, right?
有点近乎不道德的边缘。”我不得不去思考，有趣，好的。我当时有点受伤。基本上是这样的——我不会说是什么技术帮助了我们实现这一点，但当时有一个时间点，我能够获取来自客户、来自消费者的1200个字符、1200个单词的信息，并用我的算法围绕他们构建一个媒体营销活动，专门针对他们进行定向投放，完全基于他们的确切身份。哦，好吧。就像他们的喜好、厌恶、最喜欢的颜色诸如此类的事情，但要以一种非常——是的，我承认现在回想起来，是的，可能有点——可能有点过头了。我当时还在某个时候可能利用了沃森（Watson）的力量来帮助我更快地解析这些数据。但那是题外话了。那是其中的一个方面。我不得不做很多关于法律的演讲。我不得不围绕这个做很多关于道德的演讲。然后是下一个方面，财务和声誉。它们是息息相关的。你的声誉强大。你的收入就应该强劲。你的声誉强大。你的收入就应该强劲，对吧？
Your reputation is low. Your revenue will be low, right? There's a very interesting symbiosis between the two. That's a hard balance to maintain, right? It's kind of like we were talking about, you know, we were talking about Star Wars, right? We were talking about it earlier, right? The whole idea, you know, light side, dark side, the balance between.
你的声誉低下。你的收入就会低下，对吧？这两者之间存在着一种非常有趣的共生关系。要保持这种平衡是很难的，对吧？这有点像我们之前谈到的——我们谈论了《星球大战》，对吧？我们之前谈过，对吧？整个概念，你知道的，光明面、黑暗面，两者之间的平衡。
I always consider the legal dark side. Sorry to all my lawyer friends. Anyway, but like this whole, come to me. You know, I am your lawyer. No, it's, but, you know, the thing is, is that there's that side of it too. And then there's the last side of this, right? Which is the programmatic side. Now let's talk about the programmatic side.
我总是认为法律是黑暗面。向我所有的律师朋友道歉。不管怎样，但这整个——来找我吧。你知道的，我是你的律师。不，但是，你知道的，事情是这样的，那也是其中的一面。然后是最后的一面，对吧？也就是编程方面。现在我们来谈谈编程方面。
Now, protection, right? So as an organization, like I said, how do I ensure? And safety. And now legal also has the aspect of things like license, compliance, and governance, right? And most companies in the past, especially when you get into certain industries, they take the air-gapped approach, right? You know what? Let's sit in our enclosed castle, let's lift the drawbridge and ice ourselves from the world. If anybody has learned that over time, especially in the more medieval Dark Ages model, it doesn't usually bode well, right? At a certain inflection point, the sheer consumption of the people inside the castle are going to outgrow the resources in which they've actually done, right? You're going to have to leave the castle. Well, companies for a long time,
现在，保护，对吧？所以作为一个组织，就像我说的，我如何确保？还有安全。现在法律也涉及诸如许可证、合规性和治理之类的方面，对吧？过去大多数公司，尤其是当你进入某些行业时，他们采用的是气隙隔离方法，对吧？你知道的：让我们坐在封闭的城堡里，拉起吊桥，把自己与世界隔绝开来。如果说随着时间的推移，有什么是从这种更加中世纪的黑暗时代模式中吸取到的教训的话，那就是这通常不会有什么好结果，对吧？在某个转折点上，城堡里的人们的纯消耗量将会超过他们实际拥有的资源，对吧？你将不得不离开城堡。好吧，很长一段时间以来，公司——
specifically, of course, and with purpose, I mean, there's a reason why Amazon GovCloud and Azure Gov and all those kind of exist, right? Those isolated environments. But a lot of companies took the approach is, if I can't control the influx, I might as well just shut it off. And I'll put in these antiquated models where my developers have to request the libraries that they want to use, right? And you also hit the nail on the head with that too. You said, what if there's a new version available, right? Maybe there's inadequacies in the library I'm using. Maybe there's a bug, or maybe the function I call returns only two parameters and two values. And now the new one I need has three. You know what I mean?
具体来说，当然，而且是有目的的，我是说，亚马逊GovCloud和Azure Gov以及所有这些存在都是有原因的，对吧？那些孤立的环境。但许多公司采取的方法是：如果我无法控制涌入，我干脆把它切断。我会引入这些过时的模式，让我的开发人员必须申请他们想要使用的库，对吧？你也一针见血地指出了这一点。你说：如果有新版本可用怎么办，对吧？也许我正在使用的库存在不足。也许有一个bug，或者我调用的函数只返回两个参数和两个值。而现在我需要的新函数有三个。你知道我的意思吗？
Little things like that. Well, how do you keep up to date in those kind of level environments? You really can't, right? You really can't. It's almost impossible. Like we're actually going to be introducing something. I already got a legal talk from my marketing team and everything. I have a tendency to get really excited about the things that we're doing, and I can't wait to talk about them.
诸如此类的小事。好吧，在那种级别的环境中，你如何保持最新？你真的做不到，对吧？你真的做不到。这几乎是不可能的。就像我们实际上要引入一些东西一样。我已经从我的营销团队那里得到了关于法律的谈话，诸如此类。我往往会对我们正在做的事情感到非常兴奋，我都迫不及待地想谈论它们。
But I will talk about what you can currently do. And the thing is that, let's put it this way. Any organization that looks to find these components, these potential threats, nefarious components, you know, things in their software, if they find it in production, is 100 times more expensive to fix it than where it matters most. And I'm sure you guys have talked about this, and the concept they already calls it shift left, right? Which is, how do you, if you really want to combat this scourge, you know, that's really, it's really a thing. You need to put the weaponry, right? The tool sets, the fortifications, where it matters most, the people where it matters most, which is the developer, right? The developer needs not to be scolded, not seriously, not to be scolded, not to be, you know, shamed and all that, but given information.
但我会谈谈你目前可以做什么。事情是这样的，换句话说。任何试图寻找这些组件、潜在威胁、恶劣组件、你知道的，软件中的东西的组织，如果在生产环境中发现它，修复成本是在最重要的地方发现它的100倍。我确信你们已经讨论过这一点，他们已经称这个概念为“左移”（shift left），对吧？也就是，如果你真的想打击这种祸害——这确实是一回事——你需要把武器，对吧？工具集、防御工事，放在最重要的地方，放在最重要的人身上，也就是开发者，对吧？开发者不应该被责骂——说真的，不应该被责骂，不应该被羞辱等等，而是应该被赋予信息。
We work in the information trade, right? I mean, think about as a developer, what are you doing? You're manipulating information. It's what you're doing. Input and output. In its simplest sense, you know, you're building tools to manipulate information or analyze information and produce results too. Once again, manipulating information. By putting the tool sets that matter, which is informative, like static code analysis, show me where my algorithm could potentially cause a threat or an issue or a race condition at worse.
我们从事的是信息行业，对吧？我是说，想想看，作为一个开发者，你在做什么？你在操纵信息。这就是你在做的事情。输入和输出。从最简单的意义上说，你知道的，你正在构建工具来操纵信息或分析信息并产生结果。再次强调，操纵信息。通过把重要的、具有信息性的工具集放进去，比如静态代码分析，向我展示我的算法在最坏情况下可能会在哪里导致威胁、问题或竞态条件。
Everybody's like, oh, it's intrusions. I'm like, no, dude, race conditions are more detrimental than anything you could, because once they start, can't stop, right? It's like, you know, it's like, it's like a perpetual motion machine. You can also, but the thing is, is like, there's that aspect, right? But the thing is, is that by giving the tool sets, even down to the libraries, we do this. We actually have ID plugins where we show exactly where it's happening. We're actually like, here's a library. Here's all the potential. And CVE, just for anybody who knows, basically that's the numeric system they use to actually number value, well, label issues, right?
每个人都觉得，哦，那是入侵。我说，不，老兄，竞态条件比你可能遇到的任何事情都更具破坏性，因为一旦它们开始，就无法停止，对吧？这就像，你知道的，这就像一个永动机。你也可以，但关键是，有这方面的因素，对吧？但关键是，通过提供工具集，甚至深入到库的级别，我们就是这么做的。我们实际上有IDE插件，可以准确显示事情发生的地方。我们实际上就像是：这是一个库。这里有所有的潜在威胁。而CVE——对于任何了解的人来说，基本上那就是他们用来对数字进行编号赋值的数字系统，好吧，用来标记问题，对吧？
Potential threats or issues in the software supply chain stack, those libraries. Anyway, by pretending that information, and we actually have a part of our product, we're the only, by the way, our product, I will say, like I said, I know I'm boasting a little bit here, but it's freaking phenomenal. I'm sorry, I'm watching my language. I know we have the clean tag, but the whole thing is, is that we provide contextual analysis. Is the threat, right? Now, the threats are usually isolated to a particular function most of the time, right? And a library can have hundreds or thousands, you know, I wouldn't say thousands, but hundreds of functions, you know, sometimes, right?
软件供应链栈中的潜在威胁或问题，那些库。无论如何，通过呈现这些信息，我们产品的某一部分——顺便说一句，我们的产品，我要说，就像我说的，我知道我在这里有点吹牛，但它真的太惊艳了。对不起，我注意我的用词。我知道我们有洁版标签（clean tag），但整件事情是，我们提供上下文分析。威胁是什么？现在，威胁通常在大多数时候都被隔离在一个特定的函数中，对吧？一个库可以有成百上千个——嗯，我不会说是成千上万，但有数百个函数，你知道的，有时是这样的，对吧？
You know, do this, do that. Now, if you take a library and there Right. And that's a problem. That is a systemic problem, because in most cases we get back to the idea of of air gapping. Right. Or the moat around the castle. Right. Once again, you're just you're not fixing the problem. You're not identifying the problem per se. You're just you're treating it like my repressed feelings. Right. Very deep inside. And where does that go? I don't know. I'll unpack it later. I'm just going to bury that deep inside. Wait, this isn't that podcast? No, I'm just kidding. It started back when I was a kid. No, no, no. Sorry. Anyway, but you know what I mean, right? So we're providing tool sets now with our advanced features that says, hey, by the way,
你知道的，这样做，那样做。现在，如果你拿一个库，而那里——对吧，这就是个问题。这是一个系统性问题，因为在大多数情况下，我们又回到了气隙隔离的想法，对吧？或者城堡周围的护城河，对吧。再次强调，你根本没有解决问题。你并没有真正识别出问题。你只是把它当作我被压抑的情感来对待，对吧？深藏在心底。那去哪了？我不知道。我以后再剖析它。我只是要把那个深深地埋在心底。等等，这不是那个播客？不，我开玩笑的。这还得从我小时候说起。不，不，不。抱歉。不管怎样，但你知道我的意思，对吧？所以我们现在通过我们的高级功能提供工具集，说：嘿，顺便说一句，
this library is a potential threat. It could be a critical, right? Meaning that everybody should be hands on deck. But you know what? Contextually, you're actually not affected by this because you're not using that function. Interesting. So we actually provide the information now. Is it applicable or is it not applicable? Perfect example that I always love to talk about is, like I said, I love teaching. I love helping improve experience.
这个库是一个潜在威胁。它可能是一个严重漏洞，对吧？这意味着每个人都应该严阵以待。但你知道吗？在上下文中，你实际上并没有受到这个的影响，因为你没有使用那个函数。有趣。所以我们现在实际上提供了信息：它是否适用？还是不适用？我总是喜欢谈论的一个完美例子是，就像我说的，我喜欢教书。我喜欢帮助改善体验。
I love removing the minutia of things to help people do what they do. And I had a guy last year. I asked him, you know, in part of the discussion we were having, it was like a group discussion. And I, and he said, you know, what's the worst part of what you do as a security analyst is a security analyst, right? This is his job is to be that person. It's like, I always equate it to like, I feel so bad for most security people. It's like, you always watch those cop shows. They're like, oh, we're to get internal affairs involved. Right. And then they're like, oh, those guys security people. It's like you always watch those cop shows. They're like, oh, we're going to get internal affairs involved.
我喜欢剥离琐碎的事情，来帮助人们做他们擅长的事。去年有个家伙。我问他，你知道的，作为我们正在进行的讨论的一部分，那是一个小组讨论。我——他说：“你知道，作为一名安全分析师，你所做的工作中最糟糕的部分是什么？”他是名安全分析师，对吧？这就是他的工作，扮演那个角色。就像，我总是把它比作——我对大多数安全人员感到非常抱歉。这就好像，你总是看那些警匪剧。他们会说：“哦，我们要让内部事务部介入了。”对吧？然后他们就会说：“哦，又是那帮家伙。”安全人员——这就好像你总是看那些警匪剧。他们会说：“哦，我们要让内务部介入了。”
And then they're like, oh, those guys. That's what I always feel like. I feel like these poor security guys. They're like internal affairs. They're like the internal cops to make sure. And the thing is, is that when you think about this and you look at it, it's like the guy said to me, he's like, look, he's like, that's not the worst part. He's like, the worst part is, is when something does happen. Now, in most companies, it takes about 26 days, by the way, for companies usually to identify these CVEs and, you know,
然后他们就会说：“哦，又是那帮家伙。”我总是有这种感觉。我觉得这些可怜的安全人员。他们就像内务部。他们就像内部警察，用来确保。问题是，当你考虑这一点并审视它时，就像那家伙对我说的那样，他说：“听着，”他说，“那不是最糟糕的部分。最糟糕的部分是当事情真的发生的时候。”现在，在大多数公司，通常需要大约26天的时间，顺便说一句，公司才能识别出这些CVE，然后，你知道的，
the effectiveness, like we provide a blast radius, like if you find a library, because of the way we store these transitive dependencies, we can actually associate them to the build. So if I look at a transitive dependency, I can say, here's all the builds it's associated to. But he said to me, he's like, root cause analysis reports are my hell, is the way he said to me. He's like, where I have to go in and I need to go ahead and take a look at what happened and diagnose. And I said, well, what's the biggest pain point you run into? And he's like, the biggest pain point I run into is basically the effective radius of something that happened. How much did it affect or how long were we potentially exposed? Remember we talked about solar winds before? What made solar winds so dangerous dangerous was is that when it went in and affected 18,000 customers,
其影响——就像我们提供了一个“爆炸半径”（blast radius），如果你发现了一个库，由于我们存储这些传递性依赖项的方式，我们实际上可以将它们与构建关联起来。所以如果我查看一个传递性依赖项，我可以断言：“这里是与它关联的所有构建。”但他对我说的是，他说：“根本原因分析报告（root cause analysis reports）简直是我的地狱，”他是这么对我说。他说：“我必须进去，我需要去查看发生了什么并进行诊断。”我说：“好吧，你遇到的最大痛点是什么？”他说：“我遇到的最大痛点基本上是发生的事情的实际影响半径。它影响了多少？或者我们潜在暴露了多久？”还记得我们之前谈过SolarWinds吗？是什么让SolarWinds如此危险——危险之处在于，当它介入并影响了18000家客户时，
the actual issue didn't happen for 14 days. It actually had a timer that when the software started, it waited for 14 days in wait before it did its attack, right? So the thing is, is that there's a 14-day window in that time period where you have to go investigate what happened. Or if you're developing and you find a library like Log4J, let's talk about that, right? Log4J, one of the most used libraries in the entire Java spectrum, right? Everybody pretty much uses Log4J. Suddenly, yesterday, it was my new friend I've had forever. We go back way back when, right? And now today, it was my new friend I've had forever. We go back way
实际的问题在14天内都没有发生。它实际上带有一个计时器，当软件启动时，它会等待14天，然后才发动攻击，对吧？所以问题在于，在这段时间内有一个14天的窗口期，你必须去调查发生了什么。或者如果你在开发，并且你发现了一个像Log4J这样的库，我们来谈谈这个，对吧？Log4J，整个Java领域中使用最多的库之一，对吧？几乎所有人都在使用Log4J。突然之间，昨天它还是我永远的新朋友。我们很久以前就认识了，对吧？而现在今天，它还是我永远的新朋友。我们很久
back when, right? And now today, it's the most evil thing on the planet. Just so you know, by the way, CVEs, these numeric values, when that came out, when that zero day came out, one of the things was is people were like, oh my god, this is happening, right? Well, you know what? They were actually for weeks and weeks sending out info and warnings on this. Why? Because a CVE doesn't happen overnight. Right. It gets found. It gets validated. It's just scientific method. Right. You have a hypothesis of why this is happening. You need to put the information in. You need to get peer reviewed. Right. You don't just push a CVE out there and go yep there we go that thing's evil and somebody
以前就认识了，对吧？而现在今天，它成了地球上最邪恶的东西。顺便让你们知道，CVE，这些数字值，当那个漏洞发布时，当那个零日漏洞发布时，其中一件事就是人们会说，哦天哪，这正在发生，对吧？嗯，你知道吗？其实他们已经连续好几周都在发布关于这个的信息和警告了。为什么？因为CVE不是一夜之间发生的。没错。它被发现了。它被验证了。这只是科学方法。没错。你对为什么会发生这种情况有一个假设。你需要把信息输入进去。你需要经过同行评审。没错。你不能只是把一个CVE推出去，然后说“好啦，这就是那个东西，它太邪恶了”，然后有人
goes i didn't find that right so we're going back is is that saying is is that providing the right context right tool sets the proper way to do this is at the developer level and then the build level right you kind of go through and if you follow your sdlc right your software development life cycle you should actually have it at every phase, dev, QA, staging, production, right? Wherever these binaries are living, you should always have some level of security. But if you want the greatest investment in your company to help fix things, you put it at the developer level. They're the closest to it. It's where it matters most.
说“我没发现这个”，对吧？所以我们要回归正题，也就是说，提供正确的上下文、正确的工具集，这样做最恰当的方式是在开发者层面，然后是构建层面，对吧？你大致浏览一下，如果你遵循了SDLC，也就是你的软件开发生命周期，你实际上应该在每个阶段都进行检查，开发、QA、预发布、生产，对吧？无论这些二进制文件存在于何种环境中，你都应该始终具备某种程度的安全性。但如果你想对公司进行最大回报的投资来帮助解决问题，你就会把它放在开发者层面。他们离它最近。这是最重要的地方。
Stop it before it begins. Or like what we do is actually you could even pre-evaluate those binaries before they get in their hands to make sure that they're not even starting to use this, right? It's amazing. The threat levels that are out there right now are insane. It really blows my mind. You know, there's a morbid curiosity behind it at the same time, almost an embarrassment. that was a real long explanation but i kind of wanted to like give some context no no no no i think it's good but let's use that to parlay it here as we as we sort of get onto the the tail end and say okay so you we've talked a little about the the problem the setup i feel like we we got it now like yeah this is this is a problem
在它开始之前阻止它。或者像我们所做的那样，你甚至可以在这些二进制文件落入他们手中之前对其进行预评估，以确保他们甚至不会开始使用它，对吧？这太棒了。现在的威胁水平简直太疯狂了。这真的让我大开眼界。你知道的，在这背后有一种病态的好奇心，几乎还有一种尴尬感。那是一个非常长的解释，但我只是想给出一个背景。不不不不，我觉得挺好，但让我们借此切入正题，随着我们进入尾声，说：好吧，我们已经讨论了一部分问题和设置，我觉得我们现在明白了，就像，是的，这是一个问题，
we want the developers to fix it what is the actual mechanism and specifics that you guys are using? So a developer wants to build some software. It sounds like you need some mechanism where the platform understands what versions of what dependencies are being used. Walk us through a little bit about just sort of how that all works. Sure, sure. I mean, like I said, I work for JFrog, right? And our product is Artifactory. I always joke around with the biggest little name that we're everywhere, like I said, I work for JFrog, right? And our product is Artifactory. You know, I always joke around with the biggest little name, you know, that we're everywhere. But everybody goes, I go, I work for JFrog. And they're like, huh? And they go, oh, Artifactory.
我们希望开发者来修复它，你们具体在使用什么机制和细节呢？所以一个开发者想要构建一些软件。听起来你们需要某种机制，让平台能够理解正在使用的是哪些依赖项的哪些版本。请为我们大致讲解一下这一切是如何运作的。当然，当然。我的意思是，就像我说的，我为JFrog工作，对吧？我们的产品是Artifactory。我总是开玩笑说，我们是那个“无处不在的最小大名字”——就像我说的，我为JFrog工作，对吧？我们的产品是Artifactory。你知道，我总是开玩笑说，我们是那个无处不在的最小大名字。但是每个人都会说，我说，我为JFrog工作。然后他们会说，啊？然后他们会说，哦，Artifactory。
Like, oh, we use you guys. I'm like, yeah, we have over 7,000 corporations globally, right? We have almost 100% of the Fortune 100, top 10 banks. I mean, you name it, you know, we're there, right? I mean, everything from software, you know, we're there, right? I mean, everything from software development to software deployments. I mean, automobiles, space things, right? You know, like, I'm like, I love that. Like, I actually got a tour of a facility, a manufacturing facility once because we were helping them. And the whole time being a nerd, I was like, yeah.
就像，哦，我们用你们的产品。我说，是的，我们在全球拥有7000多家企业客户，对吧？我们拥有将近100%的财富100强企业、前十大银行。我的意思是，你随便说一个，你知道，我们都在那里，对吧？我的意思是，从软件开发的方方面面，你知道，我们都在那里，对吧？我的意思是，从软件开发到软件部署。我的意思是，汽车、航天领域的应用，对吧？你知道，就像，我说，我太喜欢这个了。实际上我有一次参观了一个设施，一个制造设施，因为我们在帮助他们。作为一个书呆子，我一整直都在想，耶。
I was like, let me taste the rockets. Can I put my arms around it? Can I take this one home? You won't miss it. You know, the thing is, is that, you know, with us, with Artifactory, we manage those transitive dependencies, those implicit and, you know, and those direct and implicit dependencies and also to the, you know, the ones that come along for the ride. You know, when we talk about dependencies, I always, my favorite analogy that I always like to use, especially is like NPM. NPM is the most notorious, right? along for the ride. When we talk about dependencies, my favorite analogy that I usually like
我当时想，让我尝尝火箭的味道。我可以把胳膊搂住它吗？我可以把这个带回家吗？你们不会介意的。你知道，关键在于，对吧，对于我们来说，对于Artifactory，我们管理那些传递性依赖项，那些隐式的和，你知道，还有那些直接和隐式的依赖项，以及那些，你知道，顺便带进来的依赖项。你知道，当我们谈到依赖项时，我总是，我最喜欢用、也特别喜欢用的类比就像是NPM。NPM是最臭名昭著的，对吧？顺便带进来的依赖项。当我们谈到依赖项时，我通常最喜欢的类比
to use, especially is like NPM. NPM is the most notorious, right? With NPM, you put three, I call it the house party. You put three things in your package.json and 500 show up, right? And you don't know those 500, they're just there, right? That's just what happens, right? Because those dependencies have dependencies, right? It's the most notorious. I mean, just to give you an idea, in our database of CVEs and potential threats, we actually have over 16,000 threats from NPM alone. Just NPM. Think about that. Anyway, but the thing is, is that we manage that.
喜欢用，特别是像NPM。NPM是最臭名昭著的，对吧？对于NPM，你放了三个，我称之为家庭派对的东西。你在package.json里放了三个东西，结果来了500个，对吧？而且你不认识那500个，它们就那么出现了，对吧？这正是会发生的事情，对吧？因为那些依赖项还有它们自己的依赖项，对吧？它最臭名昭著。我的意思是，为了让你有个概念，在我们的CVE和潜在威胁数据库中，仅从NPM一个渠道，我们就拥有超过16,000个威胁。仅仅是NPM。想想看。无论如何，关键是，我们管理这些。
But we also manage the builds you produce, right? So the things that you create, and we have over 32 package types, right? Whether it's like Docker images and Helm, like we're actually governance board members of the Cloud Native Foundation. Actually, the guy who co-created Helm is actually a JFrog person, right? He's actually at our company for like Kubernetes and stuff. So it's like we're doing web services and device management with our Connect product, you know, whatever it is, we have the stack to manage it. And so for us, we have our X-Ray product. Now, our X-Ray product is actually, the thing is, is if you're not familiar, though, and
但我们也管理你生成的构建，对吧？也就是你所创造的东西，我们有32种以上的软件包类型，对吧？无论是像Docker镜像还是Helm，事实上我们是云原生基金会的治理委员会成员。事实上，Helm的共同创造者就是JFrog的人，对吧？他就在我们公司负责Kubernetes之类的事情。所以就像我们在用我们的Connect产品做网络服务和设备管理一样，无论是什么，我们都有相应的技术栈来管理它。对我们来说，我们有X-Ray产品。现在，我们的X-Ray产品实际上是，关键在于，如果你不熟悉，而且
this, I just got to explain this, is that we, you know, you hear about CI, right? Continuous integration or CD or continuous development, you know, continuous distribution or deployment, whatever you want to say, right? It's just kind of throw, you know, I've heard development, I mean, I've heard deployment, I've heard distribution, you know, I mean, whatever. I mean, I've heard deployment, I've heard distribution, you know, whatever, you know, we talk about CS, continuous security. And the reason why I say it's continuous is if you're not familiar with the way that we store binary, you know, binaries, we say binaries, we're really, they're just software package types, right? Whether it's a JPEG or it's a Docker image or a jar file or whatever. And we tear them apart
这个我得解释一下，我们，你知道，你听说过CI，对吧？持续集成，或者CD，持续开发、持续分发或持续部署，随便你怎么说吧，对吧？这只是随便扔出，你知道的，我听过开发，我的意思是，我听过部署，我听过分发，你知道，我的意思是，随便吧。我的意思是，我听过部署，我听过分发，你知道，随便啦，你知道，我们谈论的是CS，持续安全。我之所以说它是持续的，是因为如果你不熟悉我们存储二进制文件的方式，你知道，二进制文件，当我们说二进制文件时，实际上它们只是软件软件包类型，对吧？无论是JPEG、Docker镜像、jar文件还是其他什么。我们会把它们拆开，
and we actually index them into a database, right? We store them as a checksum, a SHA-256. And this allows for things like speed and efficiency. So in our product, you're actually interacting with the metadata level. And the metadata has a representative context of the actual binary, the library you're using, right? And that library and all its friends that you're using,
然后把它们索引到一个数据库中，对吧？我们把它们存储为校验和，即SHA-256。这可以实现速度和效率。所以在我们的产品中，你实际上是在元数据层面进行交互。元数据具有实际二进制文件、你所使用的库的代表性上下文，对吧？那个库以及你正在使用的所有它的朋友们，
we use that information for security evaluation. So instead of it being a physical evaluation of a binary or a library or anything that most products do, ours is a metadata representation. So it's a metadata to metadata comparison that you can use. And thus it's continuous, right? Because you can constantly keep it going. You're not going to constantly want to upload things to a evaluation. So we're doing metadata to metadata. So it's a constant thing. Thus, the reason why I talk about zero day.
我们利用这些信息进行安全评估。所以，大多数产品所做的是对二进制文件、库或任何东西进行物理评估，而我们的产品则是元数据表示。因此，你可以使用元数据与元数据的比较。因此它是持续的，对吧？因为你可以不断地保持它的运行。你不会总是想要把东西上传进行评估。所以我们做的是元数据到元数据的比较。所以这是一个持续的过程。因此，这就是我谈论零日漏洞的原因。
When a new zero day happens, we can immediately notify you that's something terrible, that you're a terrible bad person and that you should fix your mess. No, I'm just kidding. But you know what I mean. But the thing is, is that we're doing our best to do that right so we're doing deep inherent scans of all the dependencies too i mean going through docker containers docker containers are my favorite thing you know what they're the biggest hot mess in the world can't live with them can't live without them right you know i'm a big believer and you know we'll go back
当一个新的零日漏洞出现时，我们可以立即通知你这非常糟糕，你是一个非常糟糕的坏人，你应该收拾你的烂摊子。不，我开玩笑的。但你知道我的意思。但关键是，我们在尽最大努力把它做好，所以我们也在对所有的依赖项进行深入的内在扫描——我的意思是，检查Docker容器。Docker容器是我的最爱，你知道吗？它们是世界上最可怕的乱摊子，离了它们活不了，没有它们也活不了，对吧？你知道，我非常坚信，你知道，我们会回顾
you know i am a 12 factor zealot um when it comes to like this kind of stuff right i don't know if you've never used 12 factorfactor methodology, right? But 12-factor, everybody goes check that out. It's 12factor.org. But the idea of it is that, you know, you develop against a Docker image that has a representative runtime that you would have in your production, right? So you remove that whole, what works on my machine, right? That's the whole thing. But Docker's a hot mess, right?
你知道，我是一个12要素教徒，嗯，当涉及到这类事情的时候，对吧？我不知道你有没有用过12要素方法论，对吧？但12要素，每个人都去看看吧。网址是12factor.org。但它的核心理念是，你针对一个Docker镜像进行开发，这个镜像拥有你在生产环境中将拥有的代表性运行时，对吧？所以你消除了“在我的机器上可以运行”这种现象，对吧？这就是全部意义所在。但Docker是个大烂摊子，对吧？
I mean, let's look at it. It's a black box most of the time, right? That's the whole thing. But Docker is a hot mess, right? I mean, let's look at it. It's a black box most of the time, right? You know, you have a base level OS that could be whatever, whatever. It could be busy box, it could be sent OS, it could be Red Hat base, Windows base, whatever. Then you have a series of runtimes, right? That, you know, you use for whatever you're doing, whether you're deploying an application or you're developing an application. Then you have an application layer, right? Where all your stuff lives, right? All that, you know, that stuff that depends on all the other stuff, you know, and remember we talked about, I talked
我的意思是，我们来看看。它大多数时候都是一个黑盒，对吧？这就是全部意义所在。但Docker是个大烂摊子，对吧？我的意思是，我们来看看。它大多数时候都是一个黑盒，对吧？你知道，你有一个基础操作系统，可能是这个那个。可能是BusyBox，可能是CentOS，可能是Red Hat基础版、Windows基础版，等等。然后你有一系列运行时，对吧？你用它们来做你正在做的任何事情，无论你是部署应用程序还是开发应用程序。然后你有一个应用程序层，对吧？你的所有东西都在那里运行，对吧？所有那些，你知道的，依赖于其他所有东西的东西，你知道的，还记得我们谈论过的，我谈论过
about the fact that, you know, security threats are based on these third, you know, third party trends, not just libraries, Docker images, and they're not safe either, by the way, you know, we also look for things in our security product like secrets. I actually tested our product with a whole bunch of random Docker images I grabbed off a Docker hub and did deep build the content. Do you know how many API keys, AWS keys, GCP keys that I found buried in these that still work? And the best part was is where I found them. You know where I found buried in these that still work. And the best part was, is where I found them. You know where I found them? Everybody's really good, by the way.
关于安全威胁是基于这些第三方趋势的事实，不仅仅是库，还有Docker容器，顺便说一句，它们也不安全，你知道的，我们的安全产品还会寻找诸如机密信息之类的内容。我实际上用我从Docker Hub上抓取的一大堆随机Docker镜像测试了我们的产品，并对内容进行了深度构建。你知道我在这些镜像里发现了多少仍然有效的API密钥、AWS密钥、GCP密钥吗？最棒的部分是我在哪里找到它们的。你知道我在哪里找到——埋在这些里面但仍然有效的密钥。你知道我在哪里找到它们的吗？顺便说一句，每个人都做得很好。
Most people are really good about going through their directory structures and pulling out all that information, right? Oh, I don't want to leave my API key there. Somebody might get it, right? Yeah, well, you might want to check your history. Because if you go into any of these Docker images and you go into the user and you go into the dot history, you can see all the API keys ever used and nobody ever.
大多数人在遍历他们的目录结构并拉出所有这些信息方面都做得很好，对吧？哦，我不想把我的API密钥留在那里。别人可能会拿到它，对吧？是的，好吧，你可能想检查一下你的历史记录。因为如果你进入任何这些Docker镜像，进入用户目录，然后进入点历史记录目录（.history），你就可以看到曾经使用过的所有API密钥，而从来没有人——
So we find these or my favorite one is I downloaded one. I typed in the simple words Docker and Google, right? Docker, Python host host, right? And I found this one container and it said top rated container. You know, everybody's like, works great. It's super small, blah, blah, blah. I downloaded it, decided to pass it through our system.
所以我们找到了这些，或者我最喜欢的一个是我下载了一个。我在谷歌里输入了简单的词汇：Docker和Google，对吧？Docker，Python主机，对吧？然后我找到了这个容器，上面写着“最高评分容器”。你知道，每个人都觉得，运行得很好。它超级小，等等等等。我下载了它，决定让它通过我们的系统。
And I found a service that said, when this starts up and you put this information, a particular code, like, you know, you you're executing with Python, do me a favor. It's going to create a TLS connection to somewhere out in the world and send it all my log files. Oh, what could go wrong? What could go wrong? What could go wrong?
然后我发现了一个服务，它说，当这个启动并且你输入了这些信息、一段特定的代码时，比如，你知道，你正在用Python执行，帮个忙。它将建立一个到世界某个地方的TLS连接，并把我的所有日志文件发送过去。哦，能出什么错呢？能出什么错呢？能出什么错呢？
And this is a number one download. This is like a number one approved, downloaded, hosting Python container. So, yeah. And I guess maybe for folks who are, I guess, playing along at home or not familiar. I mean, this is one of the things that people talk about with Docker is it's not just you mentioned zero day exploits or someone introduces a race condition in Postgres or just whatever. Right. And you're screening for that version of that Docker image being in someone else's Docker image being in your Docker, right? It's sort of the transitive thing. But I think the other thing that's popped up recently has been where someone gets a hold of your credentials for uploading an image or uploading to your repository, and
而这是一个下载量排名第一的。这是一个排名第一的、获得批准的、下载量巨大的托管Python容器。所以，是的。我想也许对于那些，我猜，在家玩玩或者不太熟悉的人来说。我的意思是，人们在谈论Docker时会提到的一点是，这不仅仅是你提到的零日漏洞利用，或者有人在Postgres中引入了竞态条件，或者随便什么。对吧。而你正在筛查的那种情况是，那个Docker镜像存在于别人的Docker镜像中，而别人的Docker镜像又存在于你的Docker镜像中，对吧？这有点像是传递性的事情。但我觉得最近出现的另一件事是，有人获取了你的凭据，用来上传镜像或上传到你的代码库，然后
they do one of these things, right? So it's not just, there's like the spread of things is very large from accidental introductions of security bugs to a long-term contributor secretly being there for the sole purpose of inserting a very subtle, very well-crafted bug, which is a very scary thing to think about, or someone hijacking credentials
他们做了其中一件事，对吧？所以不仅如此，问题的传播范围非常广泛，从意外引入的安全漏洞，到长期贡献者秘密潜伏在那里，其唯一目的就是插入一个非常微妙、精心编写的漏洞——这是一种非常可怕的想法，或者有人劫持了凭据，
and you're pulling latest. Overnight, someone changed it to a Bitcoin miner instead of running a Postgres host or whatever. And all of a sudden you deploy it. Right. You actually touched on a very, very interesting thing here, actually. Right. You know, we talked you just talked about it. Right. You know, pulling, you know, you're pulling down these dependencies. Right. And those are ever evolving too, right? Those are constantly changing in addition to that. So always being a security aware of that threat level is very important.
而你正在拉取最新版本。一夜之间，有人把它改成了一个比特币挖矿程序，而不是运行一个Postgres主机或其他什么。然后你突然就部署了它。没错。其实你切入了一个非常非常有趣的话题。对吧。你知道，我们谈到了——你刚才提到了。对吧。你知道，拉取，你知道，你正在拉取这些依赖项。对吧。而且这些依赖项也在不断演变，对吧？除了这些之外，它们还在不断变化。因此，始终对这种威胁水平保持安全意识是非常重要的。
But the thing is too, and I want to ensure, yes, I am talking very doom and gloom scenario stuff here, right? I mean i mean think about this i mean just give you an idea like in 2021 right i love i love like stats and all these kind of things right exploits used to take around 40 something days i think it was like 42 or 43 days to be like recognized it is before 2020 actually and stuff it's now down to 12 days. And the thing is, the reason why is that these third-party transitive dependency models that are threats, why are they so easy? Well, number one,
但关键也在于，我想确保——是的，我在这里确实在谈论非常末日和悲观的情景，对吧？我的意思是——我的意思是想想看，我的意思是，为了让你有个概念，比如在2021年，对吧，我喜欢，我喜欢统计数据和所有这些类型的事情，对吧，漏洞利用以前大约需要40多天，我想大概是42或43天才能被识别出来，在2020年之前实际上是这样的，而现在已经缩短到12天了。关键是，原因在于这些第三方传递性依赖模型构成了威胁，为什么它们这么容易？嗯，第一，
it doesn't take a lot of, by the way, it doesn't take a lot of very good, you know, a lot of tremendous technical know-how. You don't have to be an elite coder to do this stuff. Right? Number one. Number two, it spreads very rapidly. And the thing is, the reason why is it's something we don't want to stop, but at the same time also causes a
顺便说一句，它不需要很多——不需要很多非常好的、了不起的技术专知。你不需要成为一个精英程序员就能做这些事情。对吧。这是第一点。第二点，它的传播非常迅速。关键在于，原因在于这是我们不希望阻止、但同时又会引发
problem, which is the open source community. I'm a huge open source person. I've been doing this forever, right? And we're very accepting as part of the open source community, but also at the same time, as anybody knows with any community, it's very easily, it can be easily pulled in on savory elements, including the various people, right, who are looking for either bounties, you know, financially, or just want to watch the world burn, right? You know, like that whole Joker thing, right? They just want, you know, they're not there for the money. They're not there for the recognition. They just want to watch the world burn. But because because they once they get into these
问题的事情，那就是开源社区。我是一个坚定的开源支持者。我做这个已经很久了，对吧？作为开源社区的一部分，我们非常包容，但与此同时，正如任何社区的人所知，它也非常容易——很容易被不怀好意的人渗透，包括各种各样的人，对吧，他们要么是为了寻找赏金，也就是金钱利益，要么只是想看着世界燃烧，对吧？你知道，就像那个小丑的故事一样，对吧？他们不是为了钱。他们不是为了名誉。他们只是想看着世界燃烧。但因为——因为一旦他们进入了这些
communities they can go in and you know a lot of them wait they wait for a time i mean by the way when like solar ones happened it was like i said like it was like a fourth level transitive dependency that came along for the ride by a fix that was done to a library right and? And this thing served no purpose except for that, but people are like, oh, it must be just another dependency this person used in one of the other libraries, so just come on in, right? And the thing is, is that that's actually one of the biggest threats, but you don't want to stop that.
社区，他们就可以潜入进去，你知道，他们中的很多人都在等待时机。顺便说一句，当SolarWinds事件发生时，就像我说的，那是一个由对某个库的修复所带来的第四层传递性依赖项，顺便被带进来的，对吧？而这个东西除了这个之外没有任何其他作用，但人们却会想，哦，这一定只是这个人使用的另一个库中的另一个依赖项，所以请进吧，对吧？关键是，这实际上是最大的威胁之一，但你又不想阻止它。
That's the problem is, is like, that model, you want to still encourage people to be part of a community. You know what I mean? One of the things that really always I loved about this was that it was that tribalism of being able to go in and work on something together. I mean, look at NPM. When NPM started, I always loved what I was talking about. I started off with the NPM community in its infancy in the mid-aughts. Back then, it was like, oh, this is amazing.
这就是问题所在，就像，那个模型，你仍然想鼓励人们成为社区的一部分。你知道我的意思吗？关于这一点，我一直最喜欢的一点就是那种能够一起去开发某些东西的部落主义。我的意思是，看看NPM。NPM刚开始的时候，我总是喜欢谈论这个。我在本世纪头十年的中期，在NPM社区还处于萌芽期时就加入了。当时，觉得这太神奇了。
At one point, I worked for a company called Aptana. And we were working on ID open source stuff and things like that. So I became part of this community. And when I was going in, I was like, this is fascinating. Back then we had the same kind of idea of like server side and client side JavaScript. Wouldn't that be awesome? And then all of a sudden MPN came about. We're like, oh, let's abandon that and let's go focus on this. Let's help out there. Let's take what we learned, right? And I love that. It's like, you know, and for me, now that's kind of translated into me working with companies to say,
有一段时间，我在一家名为Aptana的公司工作。我们当时在从事IDE开源之类的工作。所以我成了这个社区的一部分。当我加入时，我觉得这太迷人了。当时我们有同样的关于服务器端和客户端JavaScript的想法。那不是很棒吗？然后突然之间NPM诞生了。我们想，哦，让我们放弃那个，去关注这个吧。去那里帮忙吧。让我们运用我们学到的知识，对吧？我非常喜欢这一点。就像，你知道，对我来说，现在这有点转化为我和公司一起合作，告诉他们：
look, you're not alone, number one. It's threat is terrible, but if you have the right tools, you have the right things to do what you do, the right education, right? The right, you know, that slight bit of paranoia, but that's still semblance of being a wonderment that you have as a developer right because you don't want to squash that right i
看，你不是一个人，这是第一点。威胁很可怕，但如果你拥有正确的工具，做你该做的事情所需的正确东西，正确的教育，对吧？正确的，你知道的，那种轻微的偏执，但仍然保持着作为开发者应有的那种惊叹感，对吧，因为你不想扼杀这种感觉，对吧，我
mean innovation is not it's a you know people talk about you know software like i said i talk about artists they are you know software are developers are artists you know they develop algorithms that do things they do magic they create things right it's one of the last true mediums in the world in my opinion that still is still a big huge green field don't get me wrong we can always talk about chat cpt and all that stuff later on one other time because i've had mixed results with that but at the same time it's like it's one of these things it's like you want to encourage it but you also want to make sure you have the right safety gates but not enough of a safety gate where people start to freak out.
我的意思是，创新不是——这是一个，人们谈论软件，就像我说的，我谈论艺术家，他们是——软件开发者就是艺术家，对吧？他们开发能够做各种事情的算法，他们施展魔法，他们创造东西，对吧？依我之见，这是世界上最后真正的媒介之一，它仍然是一片巨大的绿地。别误会我，我们以后随时可以谈论ChatGPT以及所有那些东西，因为我对那个有着复杂的感受，但与此同时，就像，这是那种你既想鼓励它，又想确保你拥有正确的安全关卡的东西，但又不能设得太严，以免人们开始抓狂。
You know what I mean? You don't want to be overly oppressive, but you want to be at least have monitors that let you know. Yeah. I mean, this is, I mean, I feel like there's been this narrative through the whole episode. Just this balance that everything is this sort of balance between, between both sides. Yeah. Wow. Wax on, wax off.
你知道我的意思吗？你不想过于压迫性，但你至少应该拥有能让你了解情况的监控。是的。我的意思是，这——我的意思是，我觉得整集节目都有这样一条主旋律。就是这种平衡，一切都是两面之间的一种平衡。哇。擦拳擦掌，擦鞋擦鞋。
Okay. Sure. Come on. I'm going down the Karate Kid path now. Yeah, wow. Wax on, wax off. Okay, sure. Come on, I'm going down the Karate Kid path now. Yeah, I'm trying not to get distracted. So, okay, in kind of, I guess, conclusion, I imagine there's sort of a couple of different groups out there. There's people out here listening
好吧。得了吧。我这会儿走上《小子难缠》的路子了。是啊，哇。擦拳擦掌。好吧，得了吧。我这会儿走上《小子难缠》的路子了。是的，我尽量不让自己分心。所以，好吧，在某种程度上，我想作为总结，我能想象外面有几种不同的人群。这里有听节目的听众
to the show saying, oh, yeah, yeah, I know what this is. This is great. This has been exciting. I'm familiar. I got Artifactory. I got my stuff tracked. I'm up and up. I love it. Then there's people who are sort of in this space. They are hearing and being aware of this problem, right? Like, you know, they're kind of pumped. They're sort of sold. They got the pitch. They got the message. They're excited about it. And then the third group, I guess, for people who either, I'm not going to say they don't have their problem. Maybe they're not aware they don't have their problem yet, or this isn't where their space is, or they're a student, or they're early in this field.
说，哦，对，对，我知道这是什么。这太棒了。这太令人兴奋了。我很熟悉。我有Artifactory。我的东西都追踪好了。我了解最新情况。我太喜欢了。然后还有一些人处于这个领域。他们听说了并意识到了这个问题，对吧？就像，你知道，他们有点兴奋。他们基本上被说服了。他们听了宣传。他们接收了信息。他们对此感到兴奋。然后第三组人，我想，对于那些要么——我不是说他们没有问题。也许他们还没有意识到自己有问题，或者这不是他们的领域，或者他们是学生，或者是这个领域的新人。
What would you sort of, you know, is there a way for them to sort of like start thinking about these problems, getting experience? Maybe the tool isn't really targeted at them. Is there like something we could kind of like tell to those folks who maybe don't know they don't know? Oh, absolutely. Like our stuff, right? I mean, like I said, there's tons of companies that use us. I mean, and so it's not like, you know, if you wanted to, like we have our academy. I would also look, we have a like research.jfrog.com. It's our open research page that we actually open up to talk about what we're talking about in terms of security. Like I mentioned, we are a CNA, we are a CNA.
你会怎么，你知道的，有什么方法能让他们开始思考这些问题，获得经验吗？也许这个工具并不是真正针对他们的。有什么我们可以告诉那些可能“不知道自己不知道”的人的东西吗？哦，绝对有。就像我们的东西，对吧？我的意思是，就像我说的，有成千上万的公司在使用我们。我的意思是，所以这并不是说，如果你愿意的话，我们有自己的学院。我还建议大家看看 research.jfrog.com。这是我们的开放研究页面，我们实际上通过它来公开讨论我们在安全性方面所讨论的内容。正如我提到的，我们是一个CNA，我们是一个CNA。
We are a CVE member authority. There's not many of us in the world. There's actually, I think there's like 81 companies in total in the world that can produce CVEs. So basically, look at this. We're part of the peer review process that I talked about before. Take a look at that. I mean, look at things like Hacker News. Look at things like Stack Overflow.
我们是CVE会员授权机构。世界上没有几个这样的机构。实际上，我认为全世界总共只有大约81家公司能够生产CVE。所以基本上，看看这个。我们参与了之前我谈到的同行评审过程。看看这个。我的意思是，看看像Hacker News这样的网站。看看像Stack Overflow这样的网站。
I mean, the list can go on and on. In terms of getting involved you know like with our stuff that's easy like i said we have some stuff if you're a student we have some open source versions of things just go to jfrog also to anyone to reach you know if you anyone wants to reach out to me it's just william manning uh it's my twitter handle once again early you know early adopter catches the uh the best handles you know and it's like i think i'm gonna make that a thing now, by the way, who cares about the worm, worms don't matter anymore. No, I'm just kidding. Anyway. But,
我的意思是，这个列表可以一直列下去。至于参与进来，你知道，使用我们的东西很简单，就像我说的，我们有一些东西，如果你是学生，我们有一些开源版本的工具，直接去jfrog就行了。另外，如果有人想联系我，我的Twitter账号就是 william manning ——再次说明，早起的鸟儿有虫吃，早起的鸟儿抢到了最好的账号，你知道的，就像，我想我要把这变成一句名言了，顺便说一句，谁在乎那只虫子，虫不虫的已经不重要了。不，我开玩笑的。无论如何。但是，
you know, the thing is, is that I think it's one of these things that learn, learn, learn the best practices. You know, when you look at a language, don't just look at the semantics of it. Don't just look at what you get. With more of like, here's how you create a function. Here's how you inherit things. That kind of stuff. Also, dive into medium articles. Look at the community.
你知道，关键是，我认为这是其中之一：学习，学习，学习最佳实践。当你看到一门语言时，不要只看它的语义。不要只看你得到了什么。更多地了解，这里是如何创建一个函数的。这里是如何继承事物的。诸如此类的事情。此外，深入阅读Medium文章。看看社区。
Look for insight into these. Look to your peers in these know, in these kind of, you know, various language types and fields and whatnot, because adhering to, you know, working with best practices is the first thing I tell people, right? You know, stay naive, stay hungry, you know, that whole thing, right? But on the other side, you know, on the other side of it is also to, you know, have that slight level of paranoia, but without obstructing your abilities, right? And in some cases, that's getting a tool like what we provide, which, you know, provides you with, you know, it does that for you,
寻找对这些的见解。向这些不同语言类型和领域等等中的同行请教，因为遵循，你知道的，与最佳实践合作是我告诉人们的第一件事，对吧？你知道，保持天真，保持渴望，诸如此类，对吧？但另一方面，在另一方面，也要，你知道，保持那种轻微的偏执水平，但又不能妨碍你的能力，对吧？在某些情况下，这就是获得像我们提供的这种工具，它，你知道，为你提供这个，
kind of provides you with that to say, hey, this is a potential threat, or hey, you know what, this library has a threat, but you're not affected by it, you know, or, you know, being able to, also to, you know, like I said, you know, become involved, by it, you know, or, you know, being able to, but also to, you know, like I said, you know, become involved, become involved, you know, learn, you know, discuss, talk. And in some cases I've done this before with other communities, right? Bring up a crazy topic that might be controversial, especially when it comes to a best practice that somebody might recommend. If you see that best practice actually can be done better, betterest, I'm more better.
有点像为你提供这个，告诉你，嘿，这是一个潜在威胁，或者嘿，你知道吗，这个库有一个威胁，但你没有受到它的影响，你知道，或者，你知道的，能够，也去，你知道，就像我说的，你知道，参与进来，被它影响，你知道，或者，你知道的，能够，但也去，你知道，就像我说的，你知道，参与进来，参与进来，你知道，学习，你知道，讨论，交流。在某些情况下，我以前在其他社区也这样做过，对吧？提出一个可能具有争议的疯狂话题，尤其是当涉及到别人可能推荐的最佳实践时。如果你发现那个最佳实践实际上可以做得更好，更棒，我更棒。
I was getting best practice, right. You know, but become involved, you know, learn. But I said, it's not just learning the semantics.
我刚才本想说最佳实践，对吧。你知道，但是要参与进来，你知道，学习。但正如我所说，这不仅仅是学习语义。
It's just not learning the little details that make a language, a language, not learning how to organize your files, how to, you know, properly put things in, you know, we're going to,
这不仅仅是学习构成一门语言的那些微小细节，不是学习如何组织你的文件，如何，你知道，正确地把东西放进去，我们要，
you know, you know, specific folders and all that, whatever. That's the easy part. The hard part is a little bit of cynicism, right? Some, well, seriously, some community involvement, right? Discussion. You know, you become a, I mean, I learned a lot by working with my peers, by working
你知道，你知道，特定的文件夹以及所有这些，随便吧。那是简单部分。困难的部分是一点点 cynicism（讽刺/怀疑主义），对吧？一些，说真的，一些社区参与，对吧？讨论。你知道，你成为一个——我的意思是，我通过与同行的合作，通过与
with the online community, right? Also being able to admit I was wrong, right? That's another thing, you know, it's hard. Remember, a lot of coders, a lot of people who do this, you know, they were there, you know, they were the best of something, right? Or they were like, you know what I mean? Like there's this thing and, you know, we want to be right. Everybody wants to be right.
在线社区的合作，学到了很多东西，对吧？也能够承认我错了，对吧？那是另一回事，你知道，这很难。记住，很多程序员，很多做这个的人，你知道，他们曾经是——他们在某方面是最棒的，对吧？或者他们就像，你知道我的意思吗？就像有这么个东西，然后，你知道，我们想要正确。每个人都想正确。
But at the same time, it takes a humble man to per se, oh, you know what? I was wrong. You know what? This is a better approach or this is safer. Yeah, there might be a couple extra steps involved, but you're right. You're right. We should discuss this. You know what I mean?
但与此同时，这需要一个谦逊的人去说：哦，你知道吗？我错了。你知道吗？这是一个更好的方法，或者这更安全。是的，可能会涉及几个额外的步骤，但你是对的。你是对的。我们应该讨论这个。你知道我的意思吗？
Voting does not need to be solitary. Wow. Bill, you're teeing up those life pro tips right there at the end. This is getting deep, man. Once again, we're getting to the end of the episode and the real nuggets are getting dropped. I feel like I've just dropped a bunch of stuff. But seriously, you know what? I mean, look, yeah.
投票不一定是孤立的。哇。比尔，你在这个结尾抛出了那些人生专业建议。这真是越来越深刻了，老兄。又来了，我们到了这一集的尾声，真正的干货开始抛出来了。我觉得我刚刚抛出了一堆东西。但说真的，你知道吗？我的意思是，看，是的。
Did I mention earlier on that? I think we talked. It was like my happiest time sometimes is when I get my headphones on. I'm in my shell or my IDE working on an issue. But the thing is, to get to that point, I need to be in a room with other people or be in a Zoom or whatever, flushing things out. And then being like, ready, and break. There's all those sports analogies you could throw in. Or if you're somebody who plays Escape from Tarkov or one of those, there might be some team action play involved.
我之前提到过吗？我想我们聊过。有时我最快乐的时光就是戴上耳机，缩在我的shell或IDE里修复一个问题。但关键是，要达到那个点，我需要和其他人共处一室，或者开Zoom会议等等，把事情理清楚。然后像说：准备，突破。你可以抛出所有这些运动类比。或者如果你是一个玩《逃离塔科夫》或类似游戏的人，可能会涉及一些团队协作游戏。
You know what I mean? Your X-Wing squadron. Yeah, yeah, yeah. There you go. What do you have all up? You know what I mean, right? So the thing is it's not solitary. And the thing is that actually all the most successful programmers that I know who have gone on to, like I said, I'm the old dude, that have had successful, fruitful careers in engineering have, number one, always adapted and changed.
你知道我的意思吗？你的X翼战机中队。对，对，对。你看。你到底有什么？你知道我的意思，对吧？所以关键在于它不是孤立的。而且事实上，我认识的所有最成功的程序员，那些已经——就像我说的，我是个老家伙——在工程领域拥有成功、硕果累累的职业生涯的人，第一，他们一直在适应和改变。
Secondly, always been involved, right, in the community in some aspect. You know, I'm not a natural speaker when it comes to this stuff, right? Like, people are like, oh, you do so awesome when you get on stage. Come see me sometimes when I'm behind stage and I'm almost vomiting and hyperventilating before I get, I have like debilitating stage fright before I go out on stage and do these kind of talks. But I get past them. But the thing is, is that I'm out there. And the thing is, is that I think if we get involved as a community, a lot of these things can be resolved through just working together on this stuff.
第二，他们总是以某种形式参与到社区中，对吧。当涉及这些事情时，我并不是一个天生的演讲者，对吧？就像，人们会说，哦，你上台的时候表现太棒了。有时候来看看我在台后的样子，在我上台做这种演讲之前，我几乎要呕吐并且过度换气，我有严重的怯场症。但我克服了它们。但关键是，我走上去了。而且我认为，如果我们作为一个社区参与进来，很多事情都可以通过大家一起努力来解决。
Can't we all just get along? No, I'm just kidding. I was like, you know, but you know what I mean, right? It's just, it happens to be. And like I said, combination of people and tools. Yeah, so that's great advice. So in conclusion here, so we've talked about, I mean, all the great life advice.
难道我们就不能和平相处吗？不，我开玩笑的。我当时想，你知道，但你知道我的意思，对吧？它就是发生了。就像我说的，是人和工具的结合。是的，这真是个好建议。所以在本集的尾声，我们讨论了——所有的伟大生活建议。
We covered the basics really well. Maybe let's tee up a little. JFog as a company. Do you guys hiring, like got the pitch? How's it like to work there? Like, you know, people who are out there looking for jobs. We talked about macroeconomics. I mean, what is JFrog the company? So I've been like a professional butterfly, right? Flying the company to the company, finding the right pollen. You know, I've worked with like, I've had like three acquisitions, took one public before this.
我们把基础知识讲得非常好。也许我们可以稍微做个铺垫。JFrog作为一家公司。你们在招人吗？刚才做了介绍。在那儿工作感觉怎么样？就像，你知道，那些正在寻找工作的人。我们讨论了宏观经济学。JFrog这家公司究竟是什么样的？所以我就像一只职业蝴蝶，对吧？从一家公司飞到另一家公司，寻找合适的花粉。你知道，我曾在——我经历过三次收购，在这次之前还带过一家公司上市。
JFrog just went public. I was, like I said, I was a mentor with like Techstars and a bunch of the other things. You know, I've done this over time. Like I've been able to share my knowledge with people too. But when it comes to JFrog, what I love about it is it's people. Actually, number one, the product and the people, right? We're actually really affecting things.
JFrog刚刚上市。我曾——就像我说的，我是Techstars和许多其他机构的导师。你知道，随着时间的推移，我一直在做这件事。我也能够与人们分享我的知识。但说到JFrog，我最喜欢的是它的人。实际上，第一是产品和人，对吧？我们实际上在真正地产生影响。
You know, like people are always like, I want to be, I want to change the world, you know? You know, like that's always the joke, right? But we people, right? We're actually really affecting things. You know, like people are always like, I want to be, I want to change the world, you know, you know, like that's always the joke, right? But we are, right? We really technically are, you know, everybody's like, like I said, we're, you know, not many people know who we are when I say J-Fraud, but they understand Artifactory. You know, what we do is we provide the foundation, right? Really, I mean, I'm about to give a talk in a couple of weeks, actually, on platform engineering, right? Everybody's like, DevOps is dead. Long live DevOps. But now people are talking about platform engineering.
你知道，就像人们总是说，我想成为——我想改变世界，你知道吗？你知道，这总是开玩笑的说法，对吧？但我们这些员工，对吧？我们真的在产生影响。你知道，就像人们总是说，我想成为——我想改变世界，你知道吗？你知道，这总是开玩笑的说法，对吧？但我们确实是，对吧？从技术上讲，我们真的是，你知道，每个人都觉得——就像我说的，我们——当我说是JFrog时，没多少人知道我们是谁，但他们了解Artifactory。你知道，我们做的是提供基础，对吧？真的，我的意思是，实际上再过几周我将要发表一个演讲，关于平台工程，对吧？每个人都说，DevOps已死。DevOps万岁。但现在人们在谈论平台工程。
It's that whole idea of natural cycles. It started off with Waterfall, went to Agile. DevOps came about when the CTO of Amazon was like, you build it, you run it. And they're like, wait, I got to learn infrastructure now. And then now it's retracting the other way. Now it's starting to go towards consolidation of tools. And actually, by the way, it's funny ising the other way right now, starting to go towards like consolidation of tools. And actually, by the way, it's funny is platform engineering is symptomatic of two things. Right. Number one, just the sheer vastness of companies being able to use as many tool sets as they want.
这就是自然循环的整个理念。它从瀑布流开始，然后发展到敏捷。DevOps的出现是因为亚马逊的CTO说了一句“你构建它，你运营它”。然后他们说，等等，我现在还得学习基础设施。然后现在它正在往回缩。现在它开始走向工具的整合。而且实际上，顺便说一句，有趣的是，它现在正往另一个方向发展，开始走向工具的整合。而且事实上，顺便说一句，有趣的是平台工程是两种现象的症状。对吧。第一，仅仅是公司能够使用尽可能多的工具集的这种庞大繁杂。
Learning it can be a little uncontrollable. Secondly, it's also the evolution of the recession. Right. Companies are looking to lower their OPEX and their CAPEX, right, their operational costs and things like that. I should say OPEEx, CapEx, but like capital expenditures and operational expenditures. And then, you know, what do you get for your TCO, right? And the thing is, is that, you know, that's like, okay, we have all these tools that cost a ton of money. What if we could consolidate them down, right?
学习它可能会变得有点难以控制。第二，这也是经济衰退的演变。对吧。公司都在寻求降低运营成本（OPEX）和资本支出（CAPEX），对吧，他们的运营成本等等。我应该说OPEX、CAPEX，也就是资本支出和运营支出。然后，你知道，你的TCO（总体拥有成本）能得到什么，对吧？关键在于，你知道，这就变成了，好吧，我们有这么多花费巨大的工具。如果我们能把它们整合起来呢？
And so this, and it's funny, is at the same time, like I said, the talks of platform engineering happen. It's kind of like the convergence of two things. And we provide that platform, right? We have everything from our art of factory product, manages the third-party transit dependencies and the builds you produce, right? And be able to do things like promotion, right? One of my biggest things is like 12-factor or multi-tier, it gives you the ability to
所以这个，说实话，与此同时，就像我说的，关于平台工程的讨论也在进行。这有点像两种现象的汇聚。我们提供那个平台，对吧？我们拥有一切，从我们的Artifactory产品，管理第三方传递性依赖项和你生成的构建，对吧，并且能够做诸如推广之类的事情，对吧？我最大的特点之一就是12要素或多层架构，它赋予了你以下能力：
manipulate the actual atomic unit of the build, right? Whatever you produce in development should be the same thing in production. With our XTree product, we make sure that you have those third-party dependencies covered. You know, your ability to go in there and ensure safety, security, reputation, and financial stability for your organization
你可以操纵构建的实际原子单位，对吧？你在开发中产生的东西应该和生产中的东西完全一样。通过我们的X-Ray产品，我们确保你涵盖了那些第三方依赖项。你知道，你深入其中并确保组织的安全、保障、声誉和财务稳定性的能力。
based on having all the proper tool sets to ensure that security, right? We have our CI product, right? We can integrate with any CI product out there, but we have our own pipelines product. It has CI, CD, and CI orchestration. What I mean is you can actually extend your current CI environments and orchestrate them, right? So you use it as an endpoint. You can either extend it or see how they're interrelated to each other. Then we have our actual distribution
基于拥有所有适当的工具集来确保安全性，对吧？我们有我们的CI产品，对吧？我们可以与现有的任何CI产品集成，但我们也有自己的流水线产品。它具有CI、CD和CI编排功能。我的意思是，你实际上可以扩展你当前的CI环境并对其进行编排，对吧？所以你把它作为一个端点使用。你可以扩展它，或者查看它们是如何相互关联的。然后我们有实际的分发
product. You know, we have a lot of, you know, it's funny is the big thing I see these days is, you know, we see a lot of people moving to the cloud. I always laugh when I hear that. But we also see companies not doing what they did in the past, which is proverbially putting all their functionality or all their resources into one cloud basket. In the past, they'd be like, we're migrating from this to AWS. We see that, but we also see more companies saying, you know what? I'm going to migrate. We're going to move, you know, we're getting rid of our DCs, we're getting rid of our data centers, and we're, you know, and we're moving over to AWS, but we also want to have GCP,
产品。你知道，我们有很多……你知道，有趣的是，我这些天看到的一个大趋势是，你知道，我们看到很多人在向云端迁移。每当我听到这个时我总是笑。但我们也看到公司不再做过去做的事情，也就是俗称的把所有的功能或所有的资源放在一个云端篮子里。过去，他们会说，我们要从这个迁移到AWS。我们看到了这种情况，但我们也看到越来越多的公司说，你知道吗？我要迁移。我们要迁移，你知道的，我们要摆脱我们的DC，我们要摆脱我们的数据中心，并且我们，你知道，我们要迁移到AWS，但我们也想拥有GCP，
just in case, in case the world burns, I want a backup, I want a backup. Or maybe Amazon works for one thing, right, with my production, but maybe I'm in APAC and maybe their coverage in APAC doesn't really qualify. So I'm going to go ahead and use maybe Azure because Azure actually has fantastic coverage in APAC compared to most, right? And so I want to use both. You know, our product line and our distribution
以防万一，如果世界毁灭了，我想要一个备份，我想要一个备份。或者也许亚马逊对某件事有用，对吧，比如我的生产环境，但也许我在亚太地区，也许他们在亚太地区的覆盖范围真的不太符合要求。所以我要继续使用Azure，因为与大多数产品相比，Azure在亚太地区确实有极好的覆盖范围，对吧？所以我想两者都用。你知道，我们的产品线和分发
and our artifactory operates no matter what. It's hybrid, it's DC, self-hosted, it can be in your cloud, it can be managed by us, all these things. And so like our distribution product allows companies to distribute to either devices or to web services or whatever globally across multiple media, you know, multiple different infrastructures. And then we have our JFrog Connect. Actually, this Wednesday, I'm actually giving a talk for our IoT, which is I'm actually doing a lunch and learn globally on using our Connect product, which is our IoT platform. It's a device management system.
以及我们的艺术工厂（Artifactory）无论如何都在运行。它是混合的，它是DC、自托管的，它可以在你的云中，可以由我们管理，所有这些。所以就像我们的分发产品允许公司在全球范围内跨多个媒体、多种不同的基础设施分发到设备或Web服务或其他任何东西。然后我们有我们的JFrog Connect。实际上，本周三，我要为我们的物联网（IoT）做一个演讲，实际上我正在全球范围内做一个关于使用我们Connect产品的午餐学习（lunch and learn），这是我们的物联网平台。它是一个设备管理系统。
It's a remote diagnostics tool. It's a software updater. It has all the things of an NBM. And it integrates into the rest of our platform where you can start automating, right? Automating the software you're building and getting to your devices as rapidly as possible and roll them back and get results and all that, you know? And the thing is, is that like, there's one mantra and we literally have a book and the book is actually sitting behind me. If anybody wants to read an interesting book here, check this out. You guys can't see it if you know, there's no visuals, but it's called Liquid Software, right? I really can't see. But it's a book we wrote. And the idea is that software should flow, right? You know, release cycles have gotten smaller.
它是一个远程诊断工具。它是一个软件更新程序。它具备NBM的所有功能。它集成到我们平台的其余部分中，你可以在那里开始自动化，对吧？自动化你正在构建的软件，并以尽可能快的速度将其实施到你的设备上，然后回滚它们并获得结果，诸如此类，你知道吗？关键是，有一个座右铭，我们甚至有一本书，这本书其实就在我身后。如果有人想在这里读一本有趣的书，看看这个。你们大家看不见，如果你知道的话，这里没有视觉效果，但它叫《液体软件》，对吧？我真的看不见。但这是我们写的一本书。这个想法是软件应该流动，对吧？你知道，发布周期变短了。
Like when I started, Waterfall was king, right? It was like two weeks of planning, six weeks of development, you know, two weeks of QA. And, you know, it compiles, ship it. You know, like that was our big joke. We even had a sign up at one of my companies that says it compiles, ship it. But the thing is, is that as the software flows increase, right, and the number of releases increase, which we see, is how do you still ensure security? Just because you're putting out smaller, more consolidated releases, in a way, you're actually more susceptible to potential threats than large monolithic deployments. So the thing is, is what we are as a company, we provide that.
就像我刚开始时，瀑布流是王道，对吧？那就像两周的计划，六周的开发，你知道，两周的QA。然后，你知道，编译了，发布它。你知道，就像那是我们的巨大笑话。我们甚至在我的一家公司挂了一个牌子，上面写着“编译了，发布它”。但问题是，随着软件流动的增加，对吧，发布数量的增加，我们所看到的，你如何仍然确保安全性？仅仅因为你发布了更小、更整合的版本，从某种程度上讲，你实际上比大型单体部署更容易受到潜在威胁的影响。所以，我们作为一家公司，我们提供这一点。
Everything from shift left to ship, right. You know, now there's marketing has fun all over the place by applying labels to things, but basically it's developer to device code to cloud. I work with the military. My favorite one is compiled to combat. And you know, the thing is, is like, that's what we do. You know, we provide that, you know, everything, like I said, from like restaurants to space exploration, we're everywhere. And it's, I love it everything, like I said, from like restaurants to space exploration, we're everywhere. And it's, I love it. And like I said, I love being able to help companies be better, right? My job is not to tell them what to do, but I can be a Sherpa and help them climb that insurmountable peak on the way up and say, you're good, right? So. Thanks. This has been. This has been amazing.
从左移到右运。你知道，现在市场营销人员通过给事物贴上各种标签来到处玩乐，但基本上它就是从开发者到设备、代码到云。我和军方合作过。我最喜欢的一个是“从编译到战斗”。你知道，这就是我们所做的。你知道，我们提供这个，你知道，一切，就像我说的，从餐厅到太空探索，无处不在。我太喜欢了，就像我说的，从餐厅到太空探索，无处不在。我太喜欢了。就像我说的，我喜欢能够帮助公司变得更好，对吧？我的工作不是告诉他们该做什么，但我可以成为一个夏尔巴人，在他们上山的路上帮助他们攀登那座不可逾越的山峰，并说，你很棒，对吧？所以。谢谢。这太棒了。这真是太棒了。
So we'll have a link for sure to Liquid Code, the book you were mentioning, Liquid Software, sorry, the book you were mentioning. And, you know, as well, you mentioned your Twitter handle, so folks can check that out there. And then if anyone has any questions or comments,
所以我们肯定会提供你提到的那本书《Liquid Code》（不好意思，是《Liquid Software》）的链接。并且，你知道，你也提到了你的推特账号，所以大家可以在那里查看。然后如果任何人有任何问题或评论，
I'm not offering it, Bill already offered it. Feel free to reach out to him. And it's been a blast. I mean, it's been a whirlwind tour through like your background, the topic of hand shape. I mean, it's been a whirlwind tour through like your background, the topic of hand, I mean, this has been really awesome.
我不是在代劳，比尔已经代劳了。随时可以联系他。这真是太棒了。我是说，这是一次旋风般的旅程，回顾了你的背景、当前的话题。我是说，这是一次旋风般的旅程，回顾了你的背景、当前的话题，我是说，这真的太棒了。
Thanks for coming on the show. Guys, thanks for having me. I'm really appreciative of this. I hope this has been helpful to people out there. Sorry for some of my ramblings, but I hope that there is some, at least some little sage vice there
感谢你来到节目。伙计们，谢谢你们邀请我。我对此非常感激。我希望这对外面的人有所帮助。为我的一些胡言乱语道歉，但我希望至少有一些明智的建议
I could possibly give at some point. No, I think it's always great to have people who have that just wealth of background and experience and just willing to provide perspective. I think we all think this time is different and normally it turns out it's actually just the same, but a little different colored.
我可能在某个时刻能给出。不，我认为邀请那些拥有丰富背景和经验、并且愿意提供独特视角的人总是很棒的。我想我们都认为这次有所不同，但通常结果证明其实完全一样，只是颜色稍微有点不同。
So this has been a great episode. Thanks for everyone for tuning in. We'll catch you next time. Thanks guys. Thank you so much. I appreciate you. Music by Eric Barndollar. Programming Throwdown is distributed under a Creative Commons Attribution Share-A-Like 2.0 license.
所以这期节目非常棒。感谢大家的收听。我们下次再见。谢谢你们，伙计们。非常感谢。我很感激你们。音乐由 Eric Barndollar 提供。Programming Throwdown 在知识共享署名-相同方式共享 2.0 协议下发布。
You're free to share, copy, distribute, transmit the work, to remix, adapt the work, but you must provide an attribution to Patrick and I and share alike in kind. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
你可以自由分享、复制、分发、传输该作品，以及对其进行混音、改编，但你必须对帕特里克和我进行署名，并以相同方式共享。这期节目目前还没有评论。点击转录文本中的任何句子即可发表评论。